hello everyone welcome to the august
2022 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll speaking here from santa fe new
mexico where i'm doing one of my
occasional visits to the santa fe
institute where i'm a fractal faculty
member sfi santa fe institute is you
know one of the world's most amazing
places to just sit and talk and think
and do research
full of
multi-disciplinary people with wonderful
ideas who are willing to talk to each
other right it's easy to get a bunch of
people in a room with different
perspectives
but here at sfi they specialize in
bringing together people who come
together for the purpose of talking to
people unlike them in whatever they do
or whatever they think about so it's a
great environment to be in it's also a
target rich environment for guests for
the mindscape podcast several former
guests have been around uh jeffrey west
the president ex-president of sfi was
one of our very first guests here at
mindscape and a couple of potential
future guests are also hanging around
one former guest who i saw a talk by is
simon de deo who i know very well uh
simon did a mindscape podcast interview
on explanation and what it means but his
real day job is social cognition and
decision making so what you mean by this
is how not just one person but many
people interacting with each other come
to conclusions making decisions and
since i have a rough informal policy of
not repeating guests here at mindscape
so even though that would be a great
thing to talk about i'll just briefly
tell you the point of his paper to put
some ideas into your head
what they did simon and his
collaborators was study
reddit in particular there's a subreddit
called change my view okay so you have
people here who have a particular point
of view a belief about something and
they want other people to try to change
their minds about it so you can imagine
that some people are coming into this
with their minds more or less
unchangeable and others are on the brink
on the precipice they're not really sure
what's going on but what they were able
to do was classify kinds of arguments
that were presented in the reddit
threads and then the great thing about
the reason why they did it on reddit is
you can quantify whether it worked
people will tell you whether or not they
have changed their minds on the basis of
your argument so they could go through
and figure out which kinds of arguments
most often worked
deductive arguments you know where you
have some premises and then you logic
your way into a conclusion
inductive arguments where you have many
examples and draw a generalization of
them other things so here's the answer
deductive arguments never change
people's minds they're terrible they may
be anti-change people's minds uh and i
think that's not surprising i'm
beginning to think that deductive
arguments
are overrated not at the level of logic
where they're rock solid but the level
of talking to each other right
communicative rationality deductive
arguments only work if you buy into the
same premises right the deductive
arguments say if i have some premises i
can draw a conclusion
all the work is done by picking the
premises the conclusion is usually
pretty easy to draw there's obviously
in some sense all good mathematical
proofs are either inductive or deductive
uh but that's a special example that's
different than the sort of casual
conversation kind of thing we're talking
about here
what did work
on reddit is personal anecdotes
experience where you say i was in this
kind of situation and i felt this or i
saw this i experienced this witnessed
this particular piece of evidence those
kinds of things did change people's
minds and i i suspect i wondered i
talked to simon afterward i wonder if
it's it's more respectable than it
sounds you know if you just say well i
had a personal anecdote and that changed
someone's mind it sounds like we're not
very
logical reasoners right we're just
swayed by anecdote and stories and we
are but there's a sense in which you
know we come to our views of the world
by abduction by inference to the best
explanation which i talked about in the
big picture the views we have about the
world are not independent of each other
it's not that we pick some rock solid
foundational beliefs and then deduce
truths from that that's just not how
human reasoning works nor really should
it work that way because again where do
your rock solid foundational beliefs
come from instead we're bayesians in
some sense we consider different
hypothetical big picture views of how
everything works and we ask what given
everything that we know
is the best of those possible views and
so personal anecdotes i have not
actually looked at the data that simon
used but it might be a way of saying
that
people are fitting in different facts
about the world into a coherent picture
in a way that is a little complex and
subtle and shows up as personal
anecdotes in those particular reddit
discussions i don't know uh the he also
looked at les wrong the website and
found very similar solutions there so
it's not just a particularly localized
reddit phenomenon anyway i thought i'd
bring that up because of course we're
always talking to each other here at
mindscape and maybe minds will
occasionally change minds usually don't
change because people usually are pretty
happy with most of their views about the
world and it's completely unfair i think
to just rate the
rate at which people's minds are
changing because sometimes people are
close to the precipice like we said of
changing their minds and other times
they're quite comfortable and you want
to concentrate on those cases where
people's minds are willing to be changed
and that might be the result of a whole
bunch of hidden things in the past right
you don't know that this last little
straw that broke the camel's back was
really the important one people might be
on a journey to changing their minds in
a way that you're not aware about but
anyway it's still useful to know what
kinds of techniques work and let's keep
that in mind when we're thinking about
how we should change our minds whether
we should change our own minds and how
we should go about talking to others so
with that i will just remind you all
what's going on here we're doing the
monthly ask me anything episode for
mindscape the questions are asked by
patreon supporters so you can go to
patreon.com
sean m carroll join up dollar episode or
more if you want join our little
community and uh every month i will ask
for questions people leave them in a
post and i'll pick out the questions i
think i have something interesting to
say about there's too many can't do them
all sorry about that usual apologies
but we generally get a very nice wide
variety of questions and then i will
answer them and the
many many thanks to the patreon
supporters because they voted to let
these ama episodes go public and just be
regular episodes of mindscape even
though they are supporting them so we
appreciate them for that
join if you want you don't have to if
you don't want to we're all here
together anyway so with that let's go
[Music]
deepti amazuria says the scholarship
idea is amazing let me actually this is
sean talking now let me let me back up
to remind you if you don't know already
or if you don't know already that we
have a mindscape big picture scholarship
that you can contribute to it's being
crowdsourced you can go to bold.org
scholarships slash mindscape that's
bold.org
and the idea is we're given money and
then we're going to choose one or more
winners every year to get ten thousand
dollars toward their college education
and we're aiming at people who are
interested in the big ideas right not
necessarily uh practical things there's
a lot of doctors and lawyers out there
that's great we're aiming at people who
are trying to think about physics
philosophy biology computer science
mathematics trying to figure out the
fundamental structure of reality that is
the goal and especially if we can
contribute to the education of lower
income students first-generation
students under-represented groups in
these fields that would be great to give
someone a chance to pursue these
slightly impractical kinds of career
paths uh is what we're trying to do uh
ten thousand dollars a lot of money but
it could change somebody's life so
anyway uh deepti says what about setting
up a scholarship foundation to encourage
students to study physics philosophy
artificial intelligence etc smart stop
start small with a grad student working
remotely a few hours a week sorting out
applications and sending you the more
promising ones for careful scrutiny the
foundation can grow later this way
you're not at the mercy of an external
organization with potential non-constant
credibility uh yeah i mean that that's
something that kind of sounds like a
potentially good idea it also sounds
like an enormous amount of work
certainly something i would not set a
graduate student to doing you know
one of the things about being a good
advisor is you do not make your graduate
students do things that are not
furthering their education in some way
uh and also i actually think that
bold.org is quite credible um i did
check them out before embarking on this
partnership with them and they seem you
know really dedicated to getting 100 of
the donations into the pockets of the
students and also they do a lot of the
work you know i've noticed we have
applications for the scholarship already
many of the applications are you know
they're students who want to get a
scholarship that's great but they're
completely inappropriate for this
scholarship they're not uh tackling the
particular kinds of questions that we're
aiming at whatsoever so
i could you know personally or hire
someone to sift through that but bold
will do that for me so that's great and
and i think it's actually going to be a
pretty good uh setup if we become you
know really
big
time then it might change but i i doubt
that that will happen you know where we
funded our first 10k scholarship and
i'm kind of hopeful that we can get
another 10k scholarship funded this year
and then we'll see what happens next
year but i suspect that's the level at
which this is going to happen right one
or two scholarships per year not a major
thing where we're uh changing the lives
of hundreds of people that would be
great and you never know i'll keep my
mind open about that tyrone says you
mentioned on your podcast with max
tychmark that you would only give 50
credence to the level 2 multiverse
eternal inflation plus string theory
gives rise to multiple universes with
different laws of physics if we remove
the string theory aspect and just focus
on the idea of multiple universes
perhaps with the same laws of physics
would your credence be higher if not why
is your credence relatively low for a
theory that some physicists say is a
natural conclusion of inflation plus
quantum mechanics well some physicists
say lots of things
some physicists say that the whole
multiverse idea is completely crazy
right i don't think that some physicists
say is going to push my credences one
way or the other unless either all
physicists say or
the right physicists say you know the
physicists who understand this the best
and the physicists who understand this
the best are not in agreement about it
furthermore i'm an expert you know this
is what i do for a living so i have my
own judgment completely independent of
what other physicists say um it's very
possible that there is a multiverse this
kind of type 2 multiverse where there to
me what that means is there are regions
connected to our space-time but very
very far away outside causal contact
with us here in our part of the universe
where conditions are different okay
that's what i would mean by the type 2
multiverse you can get it via eternal
inflation and string theory but maybe
there's other ways to get it as well
and maybe
inflation is correct and or string
theory is correct but in a way that
doesn't give rise to a multiverse all of
these things are very very open even
though this is what i do for a living
and i think about it and i take the
ideas seriously i don't get too caught
up in my favorite ideas i don't think
that these speculations about
times and places where we have no
empirical evidence
should be given too high credence we
should be open-minded about it that's
what the 50 credence sort of stands in
for it's just a way of saying maybe
maybe not
and there's no guarantee that even if
string theory is right which i'm not
sure that it is i'm not sure what my
credence on that would be either um
string theory can certainly be right
without giving rise to this kind of
multiverse that's an active question
within string theory and i think that's
different if people want to ask you know
so why is my credence so high in many
worlds
many worlds is based on the schrodinger
equation which has been very very tested
that part of the theory is not
speculative and once you get into how to
get rid of the other worlds it's very
hard to do that's the speculative part
so to me many worlds are just the
default if you believe in the
schrodinger equation and wave functions
so it's a very different kind of
credibility calculation than the many
worlds than the from the multiverse of
cosmology the type 2 multiverse
bob polk says i'm a longtime follower of
your work
and a sometimes social scientist hooked
by you on the curious domain of entropy
i've imagined asking several specific
questions about how to correct for
entropy's elusiveness in the practices
of the social and political sciences but
for now i simply want to ask more
broadly what might be entropy's greatest
promises to the day-to-day experiences
and practices in our social and
political lives more aspirationally how
might we one how might we one day use
this knowledge to make our macro worlds
a little
wiser well yeah that's a good but
slightly broad and vague question you
know
entropy is a very very useful concrete
concept in physics
and what typically happens is that you
build up
either
explicitly or implicitly your knowledge
in layers of reality right you can start
with the physics level the fundamental
physics level uh you can go to some
emergent phenomenon where there are
coarse-grained descriptions and
you have equivalence classes and you can
assign macro states which have an
entropy and then you have even higher
levels of biology and psychology and
social sciences and so forth so
a priori
there doesn't need to be any connection
between the entropy that a physicist
talks about and the social sciences
because you can do social science
without knowing about the fundamental
microphysics underlying everything now
there are two exceptions to that so that
was the caveat but there's sort of two
loopholes there that are worth exploring
one is it is of course interesting to
connect the different levels we do think
that you can talk about social science
without knowing about the standard model
of particle physics or even statistical
mechanics or thermodynamics but that
doesn't mean that your
study of the social sciences might not
be usefully illuminated by thinking
about how fundamental physics works
after all social sciences don't violate
the fundamental laws of physics there's
somehow a pattern that exists within the
structures that are governed by the
fundamental laws of physics and maybe
that can be useful or maybe not i don't
actually have a concrete example of it
being useful
the other way which is probably closer
to what you have in mind
is to think about studying social
systems in ways that the entropy or
other related concepts appear directly
this is part of what i'm trying to do
with my questioning about uh the the
physics of democracy right to think
about whether or not ideas that we get
from physics can be usefully used either
directly or just analogically in social
science constructions
entropy in particular
it's not clear that that's going to be a
helpful concept because
the dynamics that we're interested in
are already irreversible if you know
what i mean
we've already taken into account that
human beings burn up fuel and they you
know eat and uh metabolize and then
radiate higher entropy stuff into the
universe that doesn't need to be an
extra part of our social science
calculation that's already there in what
it means to be a human being so you sort
of don't need to include it again in
some very trivial sense
on the other hand if you look at a
larger level of sort of structures uh
that are formed within human uh
societies and conglomerations
maybe
there are patterns of structure
formation that can be usefully
illuminated by thinking about what we
learn from entropy or statistical
mechanics now i realize bob i'm being
very very vague here because i don't
have any explicit constructions to give
you that is true i don't i'm not trying
to hide all the good ideas from you here
i just want to sort of simultaneously
get across some enthusiasm for the idea
of trying to see
if we can understand
how
organizations and higher level
structures emerge and behave
using ideas from physics while at the
same time remaining slightly skeptical
in the sense that maybe it's not useful
you know i don't know i'm not demanding
that it's useful or insisting that it is
or even giving you an explicit example
of where it is i'm just saying maybe it
is people should think about that so
that's the the state of which i'm in
right now
sandro stuckey says i much enjoyed the
episode with nj enfield but i'm
skeptical of the premise that language
is good for lawyers and not scientists
it suggests that scientists are somehow
hyper-rational don't you think effective
scientists use the full repertoire of
human language to argue persuade tell
stories etc for better or worse
sure
absolutely and i don't think that nick
enfield would disagree with that you
know part of it is of course it's a
great title language is good for lawyers
not scientists you know if you come up
with that title for your book you're
going to use it it's just too good to be
resisted but he doesn't mean that you
know scientists shouldn't use language
or that scientists are somehow perfect
reasoners who might be able to
communicate in a way that doesn't
involve language at all that is not the
point the point is that the structures
of language and the way that they're
used in our brains are naturally adapted
to the purposes of persuasion and social
contact and those are the kinds of
purposes that lawyers need in their
everyday life whereas the kinds of
purposes that scientists have of
precisely and rigorously and
unambiguously describing the world in
very definite quantitative terms that's
just not what language is made for that
doesn't mean you can't use it anyway
it's all we got that's how we
communicate with each other you can
modify language you can build on top of
it you can construct new notations new
vocabulary words new ideas and
scientists do that all the time in an
effort to try to be more and more clear
about what they're saying so
of course scientists use language the
point is that
don't be surprised when the concepts and
constructions of natural language don't
fit easily and comfortably and
effectively with what scientists are
trying to do
ben suttles says i was listening to a
baseball game when my favorite team went
down in the 8th inning i turned off the
game in disappointment but found out
later they came back for a walk-off win
in the 9th i was sad to have missed the
excitement but then i thought that the
act of turning the radio back on to
listen might have had some effect that
could have interfered with the comeback
are there any signals that can
conceivably have affected an outcome
happening 30 miles away within a 30
minute span
baseball outcomes hinge on very minute
differences in human movement so i'm
wondering if there's any plausible way
for my minor action to have slightly
tweaked the environment or nervous
systems of the players to change the
outcome
so i think this you know i almost didn't
answer this question because the short
immediate answer which is probably right
is no there is no possible way for your
movements or flicking off your radio to
have an effect on the baseball game but
you know this is the kind of question
where maybe you have to think a little
bit more carefully so before we give it
too much credibility let's just say
there's certainly no way that you could
know that a certain kind of action in
your living room 30 miles away is going
to have an effect on what happens in a
baseball game okay
you can't decide to do something rather
than something else in hopes that your
team is going to
have a comeback in the ninth inning okay
so don't worry about your planning this
is not going to be relevant there but
the question is one of nonlinear
dynamics and in some sense in chaos
theory i don't want to wed it to chaos
theory too explicitly because there are
quantitative measures of when things are
chaotic and so forth that i don't want
to invoke here but
there is a question of you know many
many things are happening in the world
many many little influences and like you
say
in certain cases a very tiny influence
can build up and become something big
and so
all i'm trying to say here is that you
would really have to think about it
carefully to be 100 sure or even 99.9999
sure that a certain action
a macroscopic person-sized action 30
miles away could not move the effect of
a baseball game one way or the other
change the twitching of someone's muscle
just a little bit or move a bat by a
millimeter when it was swinging at the
ball can completely change the outcome
of a gain that's what non-linearity
means why when physicists talk about
linear systems they mean a small change
leads to a small effect
whereas a non-linear system a small
change can lead to a large effect okay
and there's lots of lots of
nonlinearities involved in systems like
this i know that eric schwitzgable who
is a philosopher has asked you know
whether or not
small things you can do can lead to
potentially infinite changes in the
broad future and he suspects that maybe
they can
i'm highly highly doubtful that that is
true in this case in this particular
case because
whatever i mean the basic reasoning is
whatever effect you do even though there
are non-linear repercussions they're
damped out right you can't even hear
what you're doing inside your house but
if you're someone is standing out on the
lawn right outside so 30 miles away to
imagine that that uh impact really
travels that far
strains my imagination personally i just
want to be careful and say i can't
guarantee that there couldn't be some
tipping point that you could have
triggered by that motion
i'm going to group together two
questions one is by robert ruxin rescue
who says when we talk about black holes
we have the singularity surrounded by an
event horizon the singularity is not
visible but for a white hole it seems
like the singularity is accessible it
doesn't have an event horizon you have
access directly to the singularity
similarly to how we can look directly at
the big bang it behaves like a naked
singularity doesn't this contradict the
cosmic censorship conjecture and if you
were to travel outside of a white hole
would you pass both the singularity and
some event horizon or just the
singularity with no event horizon
and then james allen says the laws of
physics are time reversible but nothing
comes out of a black hole does that mean
some massively improbable set of initial
conditions could be set up so that you
start with a black hole evolve it
forward in time and come back
come back later to see say to rotating
neutron stars so both of these questions
are about white holes and there's two
very important facts to remember here
that will answer most of your questions
about white holes
one
fact is that a white hole is nothing
more or less than a black hole run
backward in time okay it's not a
different kind of thing
it's the same exact thing as a black
hole except that the singularity then
the event horizon are in the past rather
than in your future the other thing to
remember is as i just hinted at in a
black hole the singularity is not a
point in space it's a moment in time and
in particular it's in the future
so when you say a naked singularity
neither white holes nor black holes
qualify as naked singularities naked
singularities are supposed to be
singularities that are not surrounded by
event horizons at all
if you think to yourself is a white hole
surrounded by an event horizon well a
white hole is just a black hole played
backward in time is a black hole
surrounded by event horizon yes
therefore whitehole is the difference is
what is the property that makes it a
blackhole event horizon it's that when
you cross into it you cannot come out
therefore the property that makes a
whitehole event horizon is that once you
cross out of it you cannot go back in
and exactly like the black hole event
horizon is in your future the white hole
event horizon is in your past a naked
singularity on the other hand is not
supposed to be a moment in time because
a moment of time you know you say uh
robert says in in the question you know
you can see you can look directly back
at the big bang
unlike a black hole but in fact in the
space-time picture
the seeing
you're sort of imposing an arrow of time
there right you're saying that i can see
things in the past but not in the future
there are still trajectories that go
from your eyeball to the black hole
singularity but they just go into the
future and then hit the black hole
singularity likewise there are
trajectories from your eyeball to the
white hole singularity they just go back
into the past okay
a traditional naked singularity is
literally a point in space it is not a
moment in time it is what we call a
time-like singularity which is a funny
way of
in physics physics speaks saying it's a
point in space not a moment in time
moments in time are space-like believe
it or not
points in space are time-like so a naked
singularity is one that you could
literally travel to visit look at and
then go away
neither a white hole singularity nor a
black hole singularity are like that
okay
um
so it doesn't contradict the cosmic
censorship conjecture if you were to
travel outside a white hole the
singularity is in your past so either
you're inside the event horizon uh and
then you can sort of you will be in
there for as long as you don't pass it
best buy it once you pass the event
horizon then no signals from let me see
let me get this right the the
if you pass into the event horizon of a
black hole that is like passing out of
the event horizon of a white hole but of
course you also need to flip your past
and your future right so when you're
inside the event horizon of a black hole
no future of yours escapes from the
singularity when you're inside the event
horizon of a white hole that means no
past of yours failed to hit the
singularity all of the signals that you
are getting in your light cone come from
the singularity of the white hole
whereas when you pass outside the event
horizon of the white hole now there are
some signals that do not come from the
white hole singularity and for james's
picture
yes there are absolutely massively
improbable sets of initial conditions
you start with a white hole you call it
a black hole but it should be a white
hole if it's backwards in time and then
you start with a white hole you evolve
forward in time and you can see two
rotating neutron stars or for that
matter anything else because the big
bang is very much like a white hole and
in fact the big bang does evolve into
neutron stars and things like that so
there you go
jeffrey siegel says very interesting
conversation with john quigin on the
information economy and reasons for
market failures one complication or
feature that is hard to incorporate into
models is the ingenuity of humans for
finding unexpected ways to make a
short-term profit in the case of the
information economy it seems that
although rational actors place a high
priority on truth and accuracy real
humans can place value on parts of the
information economy irrespective of
absolute truth or accuracy similarly
speech is important for communication
but truth is not always a priority do
models of the information economy
include actors who make a profit off of
the desire for interaction without
considering truth or accuracy of the
information
well sure yes i mean i'm not an expert
on models of the information economy but
the little that i know about economics
assures me that the models do not imply
that the actors are in any way dedicated
to truth justice the american way or
anything like that the actors in an in
an economic model want to make money
they are rationally self-interested they
are not supposed to be or imagine to be
moral in the sense that they would
sacrifice themselves for the greater
good okay
the idea of a market economy one of the
ideas of a market economy is that you
can get outcomes for a large number of
people even if
every individual is rationally
self-interested this is adam smith's
claim yeah and he wasn't nearly the
fundamentalist about markets that he is
sometimes
painted to be he understood that there
could be flaws there but he he pointed
out that in some cases everyone looking
out for themselves can lead to a
desirable outcome for everyone because
you know if i want to sell you a widget
and you want to buy a widget number one
i have to set the price so that you can
afford it and i'm competitive with with
other people who are trying to sell you
widgets but also i have an interest in
selling you a working widget not one
that will fail because if i sell you one
that will fail next time you're going to
buy from somebody else okay
here is where it becomes harder when it
comes to information maybe the analogy
to a working widget is supposed to be
selling you true information
but it's not but it's clear that
everyone wants a working widget it is
not clear that everyone wants true
information
sometimes people want information that
makes them happy right or that flatters
their preconceptions or that fits into
their pre-existing worldview etc so this
is why i think there's sort of a
new kind of problem when it comes to the
information economy and i don't have any
suggestions for solving it i'm just sort
of pointing it out i'm by far not the
first person to point it out but the
criteria for the information that you're
buying or requiring being successful
what you're looking for
is a little bit different than truth
right whereas everyone can kind of agree
that you know the car runs in the way
that it's supposed to when i buy it not
everyone agrees on this bit of
information is useful or not useful true
or false etc
so i don't know what to do about that i
mean the obviously what we would like
is to reward those information providers
who provide accurate useful information
i'm not quite sure what the best way to
do that might be
domas says you keep mentioning laplace's
demon in your examples however in other
cases you said the world is not
deterministic excluding many worlds it's
probabilistic so was laplace wrong his
demon couldn't exist even theoretically
well i you know i've written a lot about
this and you can you know google
determinism uh and by name and see
things i've written about it
in our actual world okay that is to say
in the world of our experience where i
say us i mean literally you and me so
not the god's eye view or the laplace's
demon i view the world that you and i
actually live in
it is not deterministic
full stop that is what quantum mechanics
tells us
so that's why i get
slightly frustrated
with people who try to argue against
free will on the basis of the world
being deterministic it's just that their
first premise is completely wrong and
sometimes they try to say well but then
determinism is only small scale and it's
all deterministic on the large scale
again completely wrong there can be
absolute amplifications of quantum
probabilistic
outcomes to macroscopic scales okay
so there's absolutely a question about
whether or not there is a bigger picture
there is a god's eye view in which
things are deterministic and a many
worlds person or for that matter a pilot
wave person would say yes there is such
a
bigger idea so what does this have to do
with laplace's demon you know laplace's
demon was never supposed to be practical
laplace's demon is not even supposed to
be something that in principle you could
imagine building lapaz's demon is
supposed to be a colorful metaphorical
way of talking about deterministic
evolution that's all it's supposed to be
so people talk about you know what does
laplace's demon know or how does it
think i think they're missing the point
the point is that the future is
determined if the laws of physics are
deterministic that's the entire point
and in the pictures we're talking about
here it very well might be true for the
many worlds the set of worlds altogether
might very well be determined that is
not accessible to us here mere human
beings so i still think the laplace's
demon is
very useful as what it's supposed to be
a metaphorical thought experiment to
talk about the implications of
determinism but of course you have to
always be accurate about whether the
world is deterministic or not for
real world what we know kinds of
purposes uh the world is not
deterministic but then again for real
world what we know kinds of purposes you
were never laplace's demon anyway so i'm
not sure what the change is supposed to
be given by quantum mechanics
peter bamberg says physicists used to
hope for a grand unification of all four
forces however gravity is distorted
space-time whilst the other three are
quantum fields these seem to be
completely different is there a reason
to suppose that a quantum theory of
gravity would be sufficiently similar to
the quantum field theory of the other
three forces that grant unification is
the way the universe works put another
way is it possible that gravity will
remain stink from the distinct from the
other three forces even when a quantum
theory of gravity is established
uh i will repeat my mantra that i often
say here in ama episodes and elsewhere
any question that has that is phrased of
the form is it possible that in physics
will usually be answered with yes it is
possible that's not really the
interesting question we want to have
some credences you want to know how
reasonable it is to think these things
so for one thing just as just for your
benefit
the phrase grand unification is a
technical term within physics that does
not refer to gravity grand unification
was the attempt to unify the
electromagnetic force the weak force and
the strong nuclear force it did not
include gravity okay that's why stephen
hawking joked that they're neither grand
or unified nor theories the grand
unified theories because they don't
include gravity
uh that's why when string theory
proposed to be a quantum theory of
gravity and all the other forces at once
they invented the phrase theory of
everything to be that it's a step beyond
grand unification
and you know the answer is we don't know
we don't know how it's going to turn out
you can't be too confident i don't think
one way or the other
it is true that gravity is different
than the other forces but to say
gravity's distorted space-time while the
other three are quantum fields is not
completely true gravity is also a field
classically
what we don't know is that you can take
that classical theory and just quantize
it in the same way that you quantize the
other theories as classical theories
there are a lot of resemblances between
general relativity and the gage theories
that we have for the other forces of
nature they're based on certain local
symmetries they're field theories et
cetera et cetera so it's a perfectly
reasonable guess that you can group them
together
but it's also different you know even
though there's similarities the
similarities are not a hundred percent
the fact that gravity is so intimately
connected to the nature of space-time is
different
between gravity and the other forces so
maybe it's not the same and as i'd like
to point out
it's completely reasonable to imagine
that in the case of the other forces we
just got lucky
with this whole idea that you could
start with a classical theory and then
quantize it there's no guarantee that a
particular quantum mechanical model can
be reached by starting with a classical
theory and quantizing it so that might
be the case for gravity that you
shouldn't start with a classical general
relativity or string theory or anything
else quantize it and hope to get the
right answer so the answer is we should
be thinking we should be open-minded
about all these different possibilities
you know string theory i keep saying has
done a lot of great things there's
something
that smells right about string theory
but it might eventually not be how
nature works that's also completely
possible so you know the two extremes
that think that string theory is
obviously right and we should give up on
everything else versus the extreme that
thinks that string theory has obviously
failed and we should not study it
anymore i think that both of those are
off the mark pretty pretty dramatically
schleier
says i hope not pronouncing that
correctly and your first ama in 2018 you
called yourself a believer the
technological progress is still in its
beginning states can you talk about your
reasons for thinking this and whether
your confidence has changed as various
limits to industrial growth and
stability have become more evident more
generally the modern era is a highly
anomalous brief period in our species
long history wouldn't one expect a
system to revert back to the norm rather
than getting more anomalous
i mean yeah this is a good question and
when someone like me says something like
technological progress is still in its
beginning states that's obviously a wild
extrapolation that might turn out to be
completely wrong but no the last four
years have not changed my mind about
this particular one and the reason is
just because i think the technological
progress it's not just
a kind of simple-minded extrapolation of
rates right i think that's there's no
good intellectual reason to say well
things have been going for a certain
rate for a certain time let's just
extrapolate it for the next century or
whatever you have to be a little bit
more
clueful than that
you need to think in particular about
what kinds of technological progress are
possible and to make a very complicated
argument very very oversimplified the
reason why i think that technological
progress is in its beginning states is
because it's mostly been based on
physics
most of our technological progress
physics and chemistry i would say uh you
know has to do with manipulating matter
at a fairly simple level of molecules
and atoms and their uh combined kind of
materials and states of matter
all of the high impact stuff or much of
the high impact stuff will be in biology
right biology is way more complicated
than physics is and we're very not good
right now at manipulating it that's why
i think that there's still an enormous
amount of room to go i mean it's still
enormous on room to go in the physics
side of things building better computers
is it some sense of physics slash
engineering problem and there's a lot of
room to build better computers quantum
computing just being one kind of case
but things like synthetic biology and
gene editing and stuff like that have
just enormous enormous room to grow in
so i would not be at all surprised i
can't guarantee but i would not be at
all surprised if
500 years from now
the century in the future of today is
thought to be much more technologically
rich than the century that we have just
experienced we'll see i'll be dead
unless biologists cure aging and which
may be a case i'll be around
rob patro says
you recently tweeted about the walk out
of the medical students at the
university of michigan's white coat
ceremony where the university had
platformed an anti-abortion speaker you
noted that you agree with this form of
protest a silent walk out and i
completely concur my question is where
you think it makes sense to draw a line
particularly in the context of academic
talks or talks at universities between
acceptable protests that should be
respected and unacceptable protests that
should be protected against for example
i think most reasonable people agree
that hurling rotten eggs or tomatoes at
the speaker would have been unacceptable
so
this is a great question but i don't
necessarily think that there is once and
for all a clean cut answer in fact i
think that part of the way to go wrong
here
uh is to oversimplify and try to over
clarify very complicated questions it's
not to say that you shouldn't be serious
about thinking about how to draw the
line but you can't be too dogmatic about
having drawn the line and then declaring
victory and never rethinking what you've
just said um so anyway for those of you
who don't know what we're talking about
here there was a protest at the
university of michigan where there was a
speaker invited by the university or
some department within the university uh
to talk to graduating students and the
speaker was uh notably anti-abortion and
it's a medical school as i recall or at
least some yeah medical students and at
a time when the right to get an abortion
in the united states had just been
dramatically undermined the medical
students thought that many medical
students thought that was not
appropriate so they walked out
of the speaker's talk and other people
have come along what i was responding to
on twitter was you know a very
reasonable thoughtful point of view
which was
we need in a democratic society to be
able to talk with and have dialogue with
people we disagree with we can't just
turn our backs on them and walk out
and as a statement of you know lofty
principle i completely agree with that i
very much agree that we need to be able
to talk to have dialogues with people we
disagree with even people we disagree
with by a lot politically
but i just don't think that that
principle applies here because there
wasn't a dialogue going on one person
was giving a speech and the other people
were supposed to sit quietly okay that's
not a dialogue and even though i do
think that it is important to have
dialogue with people you disagree with
protests
are also important and i think that you
know there's sort of an ideal speech
situation where we all come together we
all agree
to speak reasonably to each other uh
over our disagreements and try to
overcome them and see where we can find
common ground and that kind of situation
is what we should aim for
but we can also realize that that
situation does not always happen
and so sometimes other kinds of actions
are completely appropriate
i think that walking out is one of the
most mild and unobjectionable kinds of
protests even if you know this the
speech that the speaker was given giving
was not about abortion
but these people in the audience thought
that this issue was sufficiently
important that they wanted to make a
statement and that's what that protest
did in a fairly innocuous way so i said
on twitter half jokingly
that i was giving a talk on quantum
mechanics later uh that week and if
anyone wanted to come and walk out on it
because silently walk out on the speech
because i am pro-abortion pro-choice
then they were welcome to do that i do
not i do not mind i respect their
ability to do that
now what about other kinds of protests
this is rob's question where
it's more
intrusive uh more disruptive in some
sense
and you know i think again you have to
actually take the circumstances into
consideration so
let me back up a little bit because
i think that there's a general tendency
here
to hide one's substantive commitments
behind procedural arguments right
there's the substance are you pro-life
or pro-choice and there's the procedure
do we talk to each other how do we
protest things like that
and
even the people who said that the
protest was wrong said of course if the
person talking were like nazi or a
eugenicist or something like that a
white nationalist then you could walk
out and that kind of gives the game away
doesn't it because they're saying that
in their mind this particular
issue
the ability for women to choose to get
an abortion wasn't that big a deal
compared to racism or nazism or whatever
and my response is you know to some
people it's a very big deal
and more generally we can't kind of
dance around the question of how big a
deal it is there will always be
some kinds of disagreement that are so
dramatic so important so
valuable to people that you can go
beyond the
ordinary norms of polite speech
so there are times i think that would be
completely appropriate to disrupt a
speaker
but i'm just saying that as a matter of
principle i think that as a matter of
practice that should be very very rare
that should be only reserved for the
most extreme possibilities in particular
in practice at a place like a university
um i think that what matters is are the
protesters part of the group
who is giving the person a platform so
in other words if i'm a student at a
university and the university as a whole
invites a speaker then i think that
there's a little bit more room for
protest there that's a perfectly
legitimate thing to protest
hopefully not in a disruptive way
because i would always err on the side
of letting people talk but you know i
could you i would listen to arguments in
favor of disruption to see whether or
not they were persuasive
whereas if some sub group if some you
know club or class or whatever on campus
wanted to invite a speaker in
then i would say that you should almost
never you should just essentially never
try to disrupt that if you're not a
member of that group right you should
let other people listen to who they want
to listen to even if the people are
really bad and whenever i say things
like this all the time and people always
say yes i agree unless they're really
bad and i actually mean it even if
they're really bad let people listen to
really bad people that's exactly the
situation where we should try to fight
speech with speech okay
but if you're you are being forced as a
member of a bigger community to support
you know implicitly or explicitly the
speech of some person who is really
reprehensible then maybe you have a
right to be a little bit more disruptive
again i know that i'm being fuzzy and
vague here that's because i think it is
fuzzy and vague i think that it's like
it's going to be a case-by-case basis
and this
desire to come up with the clear bright
line ahead of time is what leads to a
lot of mistakes i think we should use
our judgments i think that's okay that's
what politics is like and i think
politics is very very important
avenish narla says what do you think the
tradition of physics can contribute to
the study of human society and democracy
is it the approach like phenomenology or
reductivism the tools like interaction
models or flow analysis or the attitude
first order understanding versus order
one understanding
yeah i think all of these things
can contribute you know i think two
things i think that physicists have a
deserved reputation
for not taking seriously the intricacies
and difficulties and special challenges
of other fields okay i know perfectly
well physicists have a big bad
well-deserved reputation for swanning in
and saying ah what you're doing doesn't
look that hard let me clean it up and
solve it all okay and that's bad and it
generally results not from being a
physicist but from not affording these
other fields of human inquiry the same
respect that they afford to physics
itself you know it took time to learn to
be a physicist right you made mistakes
you had to learn a lot you had to figure
out what was sensible what was not
sensible what the techniques were what
the challenges were
you should spend that much time trying
to learn about other fields as well if
you think that you can contribute to
them that's that's one side of the coin
the other side is nevertheless we should
try we should try to have all sorts of
interdisciplinary engagement and that
consists both
of individuals who can talk more than
one disciplinary language and also even
more importantly actual interactions
between people from different
disciplines talking to each other so in
particular what can what can physics
contribute to the study of human society
and democracy all the things you
mentioned physics physics is really
really good at a particular kind of
analysis right the spherical cow
boiling complicated situations down to
very very simplified essences and then
solving those essences purely and
crisply and cleanly and quantitatively
the question is always
can you then go back
from the simplified model to the messy
reality of the world people like galileo
were geniuses at doing that were
einstein also were really like geniuses
at picking out in some complicated
situation exactly what the simple
important essences were and then
extrapolating back and getting true
conclusions about the messy real world
that's what physics is good at it's much
harder to do that
in social sciences in human society
philosophy and literature all those
things okay
that's not to say it can't be done
that's not to say that it is impossible
or not worth trying to do it's just that
you have to keep your wits around about
you a little bit more carefully and so i
think that that kind of analysis that
physics is very very good at finding
patterns that are universal finding
simplified models that give you some
insight and things like that might very
well be useful in uh study of political
science or economics or whatever
and there will be circumstances in which
that is not the right way to analyze the
the situation so i think that i can't
tell ahead of time
what will end up being the biggest
contribution of physics to the human
sciences but i'm hopeful slash
optimistic that such a contribution will
be found
james farina says i have a daughter
considering a career in anthropology how
did you decide to become a scientist
were any members of your family
scientists did you always believe that
you had the ability to become a
world-class scientist
i started young
in my scientific aspirations in
elementary school no members of my
family were scientists or anywhere close
to it so i had no guidance
either from family members or from
school teachers or anything like that i
would just read books and hope for the
best so i mean maybe that's good and bad
because the idea of wondering whether i
had the ability to become a world-class
scientist never entered my mind i just
wanted to be a scientist so the idea
that there was a competition and not
that many people got to do it
professionally
it wasn't something that i knew enough
to worry about at the time and i thought
that i would have no trouble getting
into college etc i didn't know whether i
would get into the best colleges i
didn't even get to apply because we
couldn't afford it uh those anxieties
about whether or not i was good enough
to be at the world class level didn't
come in until i started thinking about
graduate school and then you know then
you're
just always bombarded by the message
that this is tough and you may or may
not make it and that's just what life is
like in between the vast gulf of
entering grad school and eventually
getting tenured as a professor um but
what i tell people always about the
ability thing is you can't worry about
it too much because there's a number one
there are probabilities involved right
it's not like you can meet someone and
say oh yes you are able to do it and
someone else oh you are not right it's
just not like that it depends on so many
completely unpredictable things not just
intrinsic features of the person i've
had many people i've known many students
struggle at first and then
a light bulb goes off and they really
get it and they become great scientists
and likewise i've had students who
i've known students who have been really
really talented and yet never quite
did it never quite got into the whole
actually being a scientist thing there's
a big difference between doing well on
tests as a young person and being a
professional scientist
therefore
if you love it and you are willing to
take the risk just do it don't worry
about whether you have the ability or
not just see what happens learn the
worst thing that can happen is you learn
some science and you put it to use in
some other career that doesn't seem like
such a bad outcome to me
anonymous says does the math of physics
want time to have a different sign than
space would something break if you tried
to write it down to hamiltonian in the
space time with the metric signature
plus plus plus plus so this is referring
to the idea that in relativity theory
you can think about the difference
between space and time in terms of the
metric okay the metric is the way that
you tell distances along curves in any
geometrical
construction any manifold a metric is
just a distance measure and in space the
nice thing about the distances along a
curve in space is that whether you move
along x or y or z
all of those motions add to the total
distance of the curve
in space time it's not like that
if you
there's a sign
ambiguity that you can choose whichever
way you want but if you choose it so
that paths in space have a length that
adds up as you go x y or z
then going in t going in the time
direction actually subtracts
from your space-time interval the length
of the space-time curve that's why going
at the speed of light
which in relativity is morally
equivalent to going an equal amount of
space and time has zero
interval elapsed and that's why a photon
for example experiences no passage of
time because for particles that move on
time lake or space like paths sorry time
like or null pads you can think of the
total interval that they traverse as
giving you the time that they experience
anyway all this is saying that this
question is asking could we imagine
physics working in a world where all
directions of space-time were equivalent
where it was plus plus plus plus there
were there was that is what we call
euclidean signature to the metric rather
than a lorentzian one that we have in
ordinary uh space time
so you can definitely imagine physics
working in that kind of construction in
fact
as a matter of practical reality in
quantum field theory we very very often
imagine that we're in a euclidean metric
space-time we do calculations there and
then say okay that implies a certain
answer back in the real world so as a
mathematical trick it is very very
useful in quantum field theory to
imagine that we have a space space space
space
world rather than a time space space
based world for the four dimensions that
we have
now
that's a different
strategy than the hamiltonian that
you're talking about here again for
people who don't know what a hamiltonian
is
number one buy my book
the biggest ideas in the universe coming
out september 20th we'll tell you what
hamiltonian is but it's a way of
thinking about the laws of physics that
really intrinsically imagines that
space-time is sliced into moments of
time okay the hamiltonian tells you how
you move forward in time so there would
still be ways to do physics
if all directions of space-time were
space-like rather than time-like but you
probably wouldn't use the hamiltonian
formalism for doing it that's my
probably that's my guess i i can only
say probably because you never know
whether people are very very clever and
come up with something which is a
euclidean hamiltonian formalism but i
don't know of any such thing
murray cantor asks a priority question
so remember that
priority questions are
questions where if you label your
question priority question for those
patreon supporters asking the questions
i guarantee i will answer it i will try
to answer it i do not guarantee you'll
be satisfied with the answer but i will
give it a good shot and um
the the the trick the catch is that you
only get to ask one priority question in
your life
now i'm not really keeping track here so
it's the honor system okay don't ask
more than one priority question there's
an interesting question i'm sorry murray
that i'm delaying your answer but it'll
eventually come
i wonder about the game theory of this
right uh a lot of people ask priority
questions right away but i would think
at least if i'm just a completely
self-interested person doing the game
theory of it what i would first try to
do is ask the question not labeling it a
priority question
and then maybe i will answer it
i'm using the pronoun i in different
senses there but i hope you knew what it
meant i would if i were to ask her i
would ask the question and see whether
the podcast or me would answer it
without labeling it priority so then you
save your priority question for later
and if it doesn't get answered then you
can label it priority right as far as i
can tell no one does that uh maybe
that's just because you're all too
good-hearted maybe it's because you're
not all very good game theorist i'm not
quite sure what the answer is anyway
murray's question is i pride myself on
being a good bayesian and i apply
bayesian nets professionally however a
philosophical issue has occurred to me a
good bayesian updates beliefs based on
evidence doesn't that require that the
bayesian has to be 100
confident in the evidence i suppose
there are extensions of bayesian
theorems to account for this but then
you need additional evidence to believe
the initial evidence
initial evidence yeah and so on have you
seen any discussions on how to address
this problem
i haven't seen discussions on how to
address that problem specifically but of
course it is a problem but i think that
you don't need to go outside the
bayesian paradigm to address this what
you do have to do is just be honest
about all of the quantities appearing in
baze's theorem so
baze's theorem says you have a prior
probability for some theory or some
proposition to be true and then to get
the posterior probability that is to say
the probability that this proposition is
true conditionalized on the new data
that came in you multiply that prior by
the likelihood that that data would be
coming in if your proposition were true
and then you normalize it
so what i think is going on in your
question is
you have to be very very accurate and
honest about those likelihood functions
the probability of the data given the
theory so let's say that you are you
know asking about faster than light
propagation of neutrinos for example and
you do an experiment and you see the
neutrinos are moving faster than the
speed of light okay so well if your two
theories are neutrinos do move faster
than the speed of light or neutrinos do
not move faster than the speed of light
and you measure them to move faster than
the speed of light
naively you would say aha with 100
confidence i now know that my theory
that they do move faster than the speed
of light was the correct one right
no that is clearly wrong because you've
forgotten
that you might have made a mistake
and that's very very important so when
you do your likelihood function what is
the probability that you get this data
given the theory you have to take into
account the fact that your data
collecting procedure or your data
interpreting procedure might be wrong
right
so when murray says doesn't that require
the bayesian has to be 100 confidence in
the evidence confident in the evidence i
would say no it requires that the
bayesian needs to be very very accurate
and honest about the probability of
thinking they've gotten that evidence if
the theory was correct now how do you do
that i think that's the the deeper
question lurking here and as you say
as you imply
there's no real algorithm for doing that
right this is where judgment calls come
in you know bayes's theorem is a theorem
it's a true fact about how you should
update probabilities based on new
information if you know everything
perfectly but you don't know everything
perfectly so putting bayes's theorem to
work in the real world requires those
little bit of judgment calls
bruno teshera says you asked ari
kirschenbaum if aliens would be
dangerous and he said she said something
like no because colonialism is a human
thing
but i thought his hypothesis would lead
him to the opposite conclusion assuming
our colonialism comes from natural
selection wouldn't aliens also be
colonialist and what is your take on
this
so i didn't remember that uh
part of the conversation precisely so i
actually went back and looked because i
was curious and i think that arik is not
saying that colonialism or not even
colonialism but sort of he he used the
word colonialism but he was referring to
as just sort of exploitation of other uh
planets and whatever
um
he wasn't saying that it was an
intrinsically human thing he said it was
intrinsically
located on one planet thing so he wasn't
making a statement about the intrinsic
natures or or goals of different species
us versus them he was just saying it's
impractical to be an interplanetary
colonialist because the planets are very
far away you know and and i think this
is even true within the solar system you
don't need to even imagine going to um
other places but
it's really really hard to get resources
from other planets right it's e it's
very hard to get resources from our
planet in particularly uh remote and
dangerous locations so to get resources
from you know mars or saturn or whatever
is very very hard and to get resources
from literally planets around other
stars is exponentially harder so i think
that's all that arik was saying now
that's not to say that i agree with him
i think that the point he was trying to
make was in his judgment it's just not
going to be practical to be colonialist
in the usual sense when the
purported colonies are at interstellar
distances from us that may or may not be
true i'm not actually sure about this i
think it depends on a lot of details we
don't know about what interstellar
travel will eventually be like
but that i think that's why i wouldn't
he wasn't trying to draw a distinction
between human nature and alien nature in
that sense
a lama says
when measuring the quantum spin of
entangled particles how are the axes
defined when bob takes his particle to
another galaxy how does he determine his
orientation
so what's going on in the background
here is the idea of you know some kind
of epr experiment einstein podolski and
rosen said imagine that you have two
particles that are entangled
they were actually by the way einstein
pedolsky and rosen dealt with momentum
and position they were not dealing with
spin but later
i think it might have been
bell uh john bell who said it's much
easier if you just think about spins
anyway you could create a state of two
particles where they're entangled let's
say they are anti-aligned you could they
could also be entangled by being aligned
but anti-aligned in the sense that if
one is spin up the other spin down and
vice versa okay
then to measure the spins you need to
set up
a stern gerlock experiment or some other
kind of experimental apparatus that is
measuring the spin along a well-defined
axis and what the questioner correctly
asks is how do you define that axis if
you're not even on the same planet
if you're very very far away well
there's two levels of answer to this
one is if you're not that far away and
we can be careful about what it means to
not be that far away you can just do
something like bring a gyroscope with
you right you can actually
keep track of what the axis axes are
between your starting point your ending
point either by carrying some physical
device with conserved angular momentum
like a gyroscope or
a gyroscope that you don't push on in
any preferred direction
or maybe you just set up some visual
monitoring system right you're literally
looking at it in some technologically
advanced way just doing the equivalent
of what you would do if you were
literally in the same room now once you
get far enough away
general relativity the fact that
space-time is curved becomes relevant
and
it becomes harder to uniquely define
what you mean by pointing in the same
orientation it's still possible because
after all if you take a gyroscope or
something like that and if it sort of
in curved space-time its axis tilts with
respect to some coordinate system well
the same thing would happen for your
entangled particle right the spinning
particle is itself kind of like a little
gyroscope so you should be in good shape
but by the way
when bob actually takes his particle to
another galaxy no one cares that it's in
another galaxy it's just a thought
experiment
trying to drive home the fact that the
existence of that entanglement does not
go away
nor
as a function of distance nor does the
fact that if you measure one you
instantly know the outcome that you
would get measuring the other one
alejandro del rincon says
in general public schools are better in
rich neighborhoods and worse in poor
neighborhoods how is this fair and what
would you do to address this issue
doesn't this only help perpetuate social
inequality
yeah it does i think i think this is
completely true and is just kind of
inarguably evidence that at least here
in the united states which is the only
place that i really am intimately
familiar with
we don't care that much about inequality
in that sense uh i mean to me i've
complained about this i've blogged about
this and i'm and i'm not an expert so
you shouldn't take my
my musings too literally as policy
prescriptions but
it does seem to me intrinsically
incredibly incredibly unfair
that people who happen to be born in
poor neighborhoods don't get the same
kind of education the people who happen
to be born in rich neighborhoods get
even
the most
meritocratic uh libertarian
who thinks that people get what they
deserve you know babies deserve all the
same thing right but they don't get all
the same thing and so i think this is
wildly wildly unfair and i think that we
should have a system in the united
states where as far as public schools
are concerned
roughly speaking
every public school student should have
the same amount of money spent on them
in their school system
and the way that it happens in the u.s i
don't know
where you're from or what you know about
the system but it's
mostly public schools in the u.s are
funded through a split of local revenues
and state revenues there's a little bit
of federal money that comes through but
not very much at all
and often it's mostly local sometimes
it's mostly state it depends on the the
specific neighborhoods and things like
that
and the local
revenues are property taxes they're
they're not income taxes they're prop
their taxes on the
value of the property that you own if
you're a homeowner or a landlord or
whatever which is sort of like the
maximally unequal way to do things you
know the more property you own the more
taxes you pay the better your schools
are
and
that that just seems wildly wrong to me
i see no justification for that
whatsoever other than the fact that
rich people want their kids to get good
educations and rich people
make the rules in some sense so i think
that that would be a very easy way not e
it wouldn't be easy because there's a
lot that goes into school quality other
than amount of money that is spent per
student etc but it does seem a very
obvious source of inequity to me so i
have no better answer to give you than
that
jim watson says can gravity waves give
us insights into the space time between
the source and us properties of gravity
waves seem to be associated with the
source like the black hole merger but
are they affected by their travel to us
like losing energy or polarizing or
whatever uh yeah sure absolutely um
losing energy is not a big thing because
you know there's not a lot of absorption
of gravitational radiation
there's not a lot of gravitationally
opaque things in the universe and by not
a lot i mean essentially none okay
because there are not charges in the
universe that can be easily pushed
around
eventually it would happen like it's
it's an approximation what i'm saying if
you had many many masses that the
gravitational waves were passing through
they would push those masses around and
thereby they would lose energy
eventually but as a practical matter
that's a completely negligible effect
polarization
could be affected by the curvature of
space-time and things like that but
not very much
um however i think the reason you don't
think about you don't hear about this so
much is because
it's just much much harder to detect
gravitational waves than it is to detect
electromagnetic waves as you know you
recently won the nobel prize we not we
not i kip thorne former mindscape
podcast guest recently won the nobel
prize for helping to do that and
therefore if there's anything you want
to know about space time between here
and there it's just much better
more precise more
easy to get detailed information if you
look at the light waves the e m waves
coming from the source rather than the
gravity waves
okay now i'm going to
combine two
questions together one is from michael
lacy who says
that i sean tweeted the following quote
a.i is nowhere close to being conscious
or self-aware but it's getting pretty
good at faking it and will get even
better very quickly that would be
transformative although in different
ways than honest agi would be unquote so
michael is asking how will we know when
honest agi has been achieved ai this
very good at faking faking it can pass
the touring test since that's designed
to detect human-like behavior rather
than actual intelligence or
self-awareness
will we ever be able to distinguish
between sophisticated ai and self-aware
agi without developing equations to
define consciousness as an emergent
phenomenon and then joy kolbeck says
so it turns out that russian chess
robots are not only plenty strong enough
to break children's fingers
but we'll do it to just because the
child violated the usual procedure
taking his move too quickly do you think
we are ready to accept slash trust robot
helpers in our homes anytime soon so
these are i mean i may or may not be
doing the right thing by grouping these
two questions together but i think of
them as flip sides of the same coin
michael is saying okay given that ai is
pretty good at faking it how will we
ever know when we actually do achieve
consciousness in artificial intelligence
and joy is saying given that ai is not
conscious is is you know not beholden to
rules of common sense and morality that
human beings are when are we able to
accept or trust it um to joy's question
first i think it's the easier one do you
think we're ready to accept or trust
robot helpers in our homes anytime soon
yes
clearly empirically we are if you have a
roomba in your house you are in some
sense willing to accept and trust robot
helpers it's just a very low capacity
kind of robot it's not able to break
your fingers um
there's no hard and fast line between
robots and other kinds of technology
right almost all technology certainly
cars or microwave ovens or whatever have
a lot of computer programming in them as
well as a lot of moving parts and have
both dangers and benefits and we very
happily put up with them and so the
point of my tweet that michael referred
to is
that
ai will in some sense become more and
more ubiquitous uh
the ability to act human-like if you
take that to be what we mean by ai in
this sense um that it's gonna be there
so you know if joy if you're saying
are we going to accept it i think yes is
clearly the answer should we be well i
think it's okay but
i do think we need to understand and be
cognizant of the dangers you know i
think that the story that everyone
probably knows is about the russian
chess robot that literally moves pieces
around but it thought that the
child it was playing against was
cheating and so it reached out and broke
the child's finger which is obviously
just
bad design on the that particular robot
but there's lots of things that can be
badly designed even if they're not ai so
i don't think that's a problem unique to
artificial intelligence to michael's
question you know the clear answer is
that i don't know okay when honest agi
will be achieved and i don't even
uh know if it's knowable but what i
wanna i mean the point i'll just
reiterate sort of the deeper thought
behind the tweet which is that
it's way easier to fake being human than
to be human okay
and
i think that therefore the worries about
super intelligent a.i
are perhaps not the most immediate
worries we should be worried about
there's other worries not that i'm
downplaying the potential threats of
super intelligent you know vastly
powerful ais sure that that's a that's a
worry
what i do worry about much more short
term and obviously are programs that
will fool people into thinking that
they're human even though they're not
that opens up a whole new bag of worms
bag of worms can of worms that we
haven't thought about that much so it's
it's a
instance of the fact that
our imaginations are highly
non-uniform we're very easily to imagine
able to imagine things that are like
things we experience but with a slight
tweak somehow right so perversely it's
easier for us to imagine
robots or ais that behave humanly
than it is the vast spectrum of
behaviors in between in in-hume
completely non-human and human behaviors
right so i think there's just a lot of
phase space a lot of design space open
for human quasi-human-like behaviors on
the part of ais that have not even a
semblance of actual intelligence or
common sense or values behind them i
think that's a much more short-term
important issue than super intelligence
or agi or anything like that
brendan asks i'm curious how ariel and
caliban manage to travel across country
did you end up flying or driving them uh
we flew them and i cannot imagine
driving from one coast of the united
states to the other with two cats with
you know cat box and and food and
all that kind of worry together so we
flew
and it was interesting because you know
their brother and sister and they've
grown up together they've never been
apart but their personalities are
different and they have sort of
different levels of courage in different
circumstances you know if you're
vacuuming taliban is the biggest fraidy
cat in the world he will hide behind
some big object and he will not come out
if that vacuum is going whereas ariel
will stand up to the vacuum cleaner and
in some sense you know she's a little
bit more territorial you know she'll
protect her ground more than caliban
will
it's the opposite when they are
traveling caliban took it like a champ
once we got them into the cat carriers
uh you know it is a traumatic thing they
have no idea what's going on they they
knew that for the past couple days there
were noises and weird things going on in
their house because the movers were
there etc so they were already a little
bit freaked out
and caliban you know i don't want to
project onto him but he seemed to kind
of like it
he was like looking around and you know
he was ready to you know say hi to
people and didn't raise a fuss when we
were actually in the plane and very soon
after getting to the apartment in
baltimore he was walking around and you
know looking at his new home and
figuring out what spaces were going to
be his where the sunbeams were et cetera
ariel did not take it well at all she
was frightened the whole time you know
we did everything we could to reassure
her but she was just not happy
and it's taken her a while to sort of
crawl out from her you know dark
comfortable places even in the new house
in baltimore she's finally doing it now
she is adjusting the great thing about
cats are is uh short-term memories they
do not really linger on in their worries
so she's adapting fine now but yeah i
could imagine honestly if we only had
caliban i could imagine he could be a
traveling cat ariel there's no chance
that you'd ever be a traveling cat
kathy sieger says no proper question
this time around but i'd be happy if you
could recommend a book a fiction book
think of a book you really loved no
matter what genre thank you
so
i always you know i hesitated these
kinds of questions i have some you know
standard answers to give
but
i'm very well aware that different kinds
of people like different kinds of books
you know i'm not a
moral objectivist or an aesthetic
objectivist either i don't think there's
such a thing as the best books that
everyone should read so my standard
answer if you you know forced me to say
what is my favorite book of all time
pride and prejudice by jane austen
uh i just love reading that book read it
over and over again and it's it's
clearly you know it's not science
fictiony or anything like that but
austin was just better than anyone i've
ever read at
getting all of the little details of
human thought exactly right okay
and
that doesn't mean it's for everybody
like if you are into it if you get it
it is one of the funniest books you'll
ever read it's a page turner uh and it's
quite moving in places and the
characters are just lovable and
hilarious
um but if you don't get for example the
fact that jane austen
very very often speaks in
you know even though it's not first
person narration she very often speaks
in the voice
that one of her characters would use
okay so she's speaking
in the kind of thought process that
would belong to one of the characters
not to her the
author and even sometimes she's speaking
sort of in the voice of conventional
wisdom even though she doesn't believe
in the conventional wisdom so there's an
enormous amount of sarcasm and
facetiousness and
mockery going on teasing in jane austen
and sometimes people read it literally
and don't get it and they think this is
horrible
and you know likewise if it's it's slow
moving in terms of action scenes if you
want to see a lot of chase scenes then
uh pride and prejudice is not the thing
to read
um two more books that i will that i
name drop in these circumstances one is
the moon is a harsh mistress by robert
heinlein science fiction book about a
revolution on the moon that was my
favorite book as a kid growing up when i
was reading all the science fiction
stuff i recently reread it and i claim
that it holds up 100
still love that book it's it's just
rich
fully imagined and very very easy to
read it's written in a
sort of
dialect that he made up so that's a tiny
tiny barrier to entry right at the start
but there's no real difficulty reading
it
um and the other one is mason and dixon
by thomas pension thomas pension
famously a living american writer who is
uh one of the leader of post-modern
literature in the 60s 70s 80s etc
mason and dixon is my favorite book by
him it's also written in
a very thick dialect that does require
an enormous amount of effort so compared
to the other two books mason and dixon
requires an enormous amount of
uh commitment on the part of the reader
but it totally pays off it is again so
well done so rich so hilarious
um both
intellectually stimulating and kind of
goofy and silly and crazy at times and
like all pension works you know it's
sometimes hard to know
who's talking which scene this is in
where we are why we're doing it you got
to sort of live up live through that
push through and i i think the reward is
is absolutely there gravity's rainbow is
of course pension's most famous book and
that is
sort of
all the difficulties of mason and dixon
with the difficult language the
difficulty of knowing where you are and
what's going on are amplified by a lot
in gravity's rainbow and i and i think
that gravity's rainbow is actually one
of his earlier works
um and he was a little bit less good at
the human side of things he was a little
bit overly intellectualized and there's
some very very human moments there in
gravity's rainbow but
the characters are just much more alive
and personable and interesting to me in
mason and dixon than they were in
gravity's rainbow okay i'm going to
group another two questions together one
is from eric dovidgee who says how did
einstein go from having an intuition
about the nature of space and time to
actually getting his pencil out and
figuring out those field equations in
other words can you talk about the
methodology of theoretical physicists
and sean herbison says what does a
theoretical physicist actually do on a
day-to-day basis to work on physics i
know there are a lot of other things you
do teaching getting grants and such but
what's the actual physics work look like
broadly speaking i'm assuming it
involves at least research and some form
of equation crunching but i'm curious to
get a better picture
so obviously the difference between
these two questions is one involves me
and the other one involves albert
einstein which is probably a very large
difference but nevertheless there are
similarities when it comes to how
theoretical physics gets done i mean we
can talk about einstein first but it
isn't necessarily representative sample
because you know it's einstein but
einstein was obviously extraordinarily
smart uh don't need to tell you that he
was not the world's best mathematician
he was best mathematician he was really
really good at math don't get me wrong
but it wasn't his specialty what he was
really a genius at was this kind of
thought experiment analysis figuring out
what was important what was not as we
already talked about
um
so it came to the point in the you know
early 20th century where he had figured
out special relativity
basically many other people have put
together pieces of special relativity
and einstein's main accomplishment if
anything was just to say you don't need
this stuff called the ether anymore you
can just change your notions of space
and time and get all the right answers
out what he didn't do at the time 1905
was to say that space and time should be
married together to make space time that
came two years later by hermann
minkowski who was one of einstein's old
professors
and who was a mathematician and and he
had this elegant way of thinking about
special relativity in terms of
space-time which we now call minkowski
space-time
and einstein actually didn't like it he
thought it was just showing off
mathematically a little bit too
uh complicated and who needs that we're
all physicists right but he was of
course thinking about this question of
gravity because once you have special
relativity once you have this new view
of space and time
it's kind of like when you have quantum
mechanics and you have to go back and
all of your classical theories need to
be updated to become quantum theories
when you have relativity you have to go
back and all of your newtonian theories
have to may be made relativistic happily
electromagnetism was already
relativistic electromagnetism was the
inspiration for relativity but newtonian
gravity was different so fitting gravity
into special relativity was an obvious
thing to think about
and it was the principle
of equivalence that really got him going
which was exactly his sort of thought
experiment genius where he realized that
if you didn't know that you were in a
gravitational field you couldn't
necessarily tell the difference between
let's say being in a house on earth with
no windows versus being in a spaceship
that was accelerating at one g
and that means that gravity is universal
and that means that gravity if you're
einstein it means the gravity is a
feature of space-time itself
and he thought about that a lot and he
he actually i'm not exactly sure how it
happened but he came up with the idea
that maybe the curvature of space-time
the geometry of space-time could be what
was going on he didn't know anything
about what at that point was the modern
view of geometry okay uh that's
something that was a specific thing that
mathematicians knew about that had been
invented by gauss and riemann and their
successors in the
last half of the 19th century
so einstein sort of got the idea that
maybe he should catch up and he talked
to friends of his marshall grossman in
particular was a good friend of his who
knew all this fancy rimani and geometry
stuff and so he learned it so
what what was involved in einstein
inventing general relativity you know
reading books and papers about romanian
geometry was a big part of it uh so
first getting the idea that you needed
to know riemanni in geometry then
learning it and then asking yourself the
physics question okay
if this is the math behind understanding
curve space time how can i turn it into
physics so how can i use the
mathematical quantities that are defined
by riemann etc and relate them to
physical quantities like
planets moving around the sun in orbits
and stuff like that so you need to have
the equivalent of mass right because
mass is the source of gravity newtonian
physics so einstein had to figure out
that there was there would be a tensor
which we now call the energy momentum
tensor or the stress energy tensor that
would replace the idea of mass and he
had to relate that tensor to something
involving the curvature of space-time
and there's a lot of trial and error
honestly you know he he guessed you know
he pushed around symbols he said you
know what could fit with what he was
still brand new at it so he he didn't
hadn't quite absorbed all the intuition
and tricks of rimani in geometry but he
eventually got there
so a lot of it i think besides the
studying other people's stuff a lot of
it is just pencil and paper you're
scribbling equations you're drawing
little doodles you're asking yourself
what should fit together the math is
crystal clear but turning into physics
is hard
and so for sean herbison you know it's
not that different even if you're a
modern theoretical physicist if you're a
pencil and paper physicist like myself
okay so many physicists of course these
days use computers to simulate things
but there's still a lot of us who are
sitting at our pads either ipads or pads
of paper and scribbling equations
scribbling at the board
some of it is exactly you know well i
mean all of it is exactly like what
einstein did in some sense because
remember i mentioned marshall grossman
who was einstein's friend and also tutor
in rimani in geometry so talking to
other people is an important thing it's
a great story that i actually mentioned
in um the biggest ideas in the universe
coming out in a short time because i
talk about einstein's equation i derive
einstein's equation in some sense for
you and so i discuss what all the
symbols mean and so forth
and you know everyone knew each other
like everyone knew that einstein was
thinking about gravity he had made
proposals along the way you know you
write papers updating people on your
progress and so he talked to people and
in fact david hilbert the famous
mathematician
invited einstein to go give a series of
lectures at gerdagan where hilbert was a
professor which einstein did i literally
stayed at hilbert's house and guess what
they talked about math and physics all
the time and as a result hilbert was
inspired to think about gravity and
curved space-time and he came up with a
different way to derive what we now know
as einstein's equation and
it worked really well in fact we call it
the einstein hilbert action he used the
action principle the principle of least
action to derive einstein's same field
equations so talking to people
standing at the board scribbling
equations sitting by yourself scribbling
equations trying to fit together the
math and the physics
there is a balance between asking the
right question
and coming up with the techniques to
answer that question right and how you
do this in either case is kind of
mysterious i did i guess the last thing
i will say is i did write a series of
blog posts on the evolution of a paper
uh this was several years ago but one of
the first
papers that i wrote after coming to
caltech was with a graduate student at
the time lottie ackerman and mark wise
my colleague there and i explained in a
series of three blog posts how precisely
that
paper came to be written and that gives
you if you want to look at that um it'll
give you a picture of how theoretical
physics gets done it started with an
idea that lottie had she just had a
quest a question
um you know how what would happen if
inflation happened at different speeds
in different directions in the early
universe and she asked mark about it and
mark was like oh yeah we could probably
calculate some predictable observable
consequences of this in the microwave
background and then they brought me in
and i said
yeah in fact there's this kind of energy
source that would make that happen and
there's also you know these tricks to
doing the cmb calculations so the three
of us collaborated and put that together
if you want to check that out
cubit says there are quite a few times
when you mention that classical
mechanics is just a limit of quantum
mechanics i wonder how settled this
debate is what about the spread of a
free object in space that the
schrodinger equation predicts but is not
seen in our everyday life seems like we
need many worlds in order to explain
this and it must therefore be highly
controversial well we don't need many
worlds to explain the classical limit of
quantum mechanics you know whenever
you're tempted to say we need many
worlds to explain something
what you really should be asking is are
there other models that also explain it
and in this case sure there are other
models of quantum mechanics that also
have the classical limit just as well
but you are correct in putting your
finger on something tricky and slippery
about the classical limit of quantum
mechanics it it doesn't seem robust in
some sense and this is what schroedinger
himself
uh struggled with you know he was he was
hoping that his equation for the wave
function would describe a wave that kind
of bundled up and came together and
looked particle like a wave packet
but it doesn't it does the opposite a
free particle in the schrodinger picture
will spread out all over the universe so
why doesn't the universe quickly become
non-classical and look very quantum well
there's at least two things going on one
is that when the degrees of freedom that
we're talking about
whatever that is so maybe you're talking
about the earth okay the earth has a
center of mass and you can talk about
its quantum mechanical evolution of the
center of mass of the earth but when
those degrees of freedom become very
very massive like the earth then you can
show that the rate at which the wave
function spreads out is much much
smaller okay heavy objects act more
naturally classical than light ones do
and the things that we come across in
our everyday classical lives are
generally very very heavy their wave
packet spreading is not very noticeable
that's the easy part and that part is
traditionally taught in quantum
mechanics courses the hard part is you
also need to talk about decoherence you
need to talk about why wave packets are
concentrated in the first place and that
is a subtle question having to do with
pointer states and decoherence and
complicated things like that and and
there i think honestly i don't think the
story is settled yet there's been heroic
work done by people like wojtek zurak
and others on the emergence of
classicality and why certain states show
up in the world but i i think that
there's still a little bit of work
remaining to be done before everyone
agrees on precisely the right story to
tell
ronald buck says 10 second question
other than attending a book signing is
there any way to get an autographed copy
uh short answer no
i mean people do ask this but there just
isn't a way and i i keep thinking that
maybe we should get there to be away way
but i don't want that way to involve me
taking a book and packing it up and
taking it to the post office so
maybe you should be asking the publisher
rather than me
if the publisher wants to set up some
way to that i sign a hundred books and
they sell them at some different rate
that would be fine with me or some
bookstore or something like that but
there's no system right now in place for
that
dan pie says i recently read sam
harris's the moral landscape and it
occurred to me that there seems to be
very little practical difference between
his moral objectivism and your moral
constructivism despite the radical
ontological differences
both postulate that there are correct
answers to moral questions that reason
can help us discover and to persuade
others to accept do you find value in
harris's approach to morality despite
the argument's central is ought problem
well i think that you know you're right
that there are two different questions
to ask what is
one is sort of ethical and one is
meta-ethical okay so the ethical
questions are what do you actually think
are the rules are right and wrong are
principles of moral behavior the
meta-ethical principle the question is
why how can we justify those principles
why do we think that these certain
principles are
the right ones to choose and the
obvious difference between sam harris
and myself is on the meta ethical level
i think that the
arguments that he puts forward to go
from uh the to to do the science of
morality as he and other people have
called it are extremely unconvincing to
me now we might very well end up in the
same ethical places i actually don't
know i don't know what uh sam would put
forward
i'm not even sure my own ethical
principles are so it's impossible for me
to say that someone else has the same
ethical principles as myself um but
i think that the meta-ethical question
is really important here it's certainly
not surprising to me that someone can be
a moral objectivist and come up with the
same exact ethical principles as a moral
constructivist because from the moral
constructivists point of view
there are no objective moral rules right
there are just our moral intuitions and
we sort of say
as a matter of agreement you know let's
behave this way and sometimes we
disagree and then we throw people in
jail or we get in fights or whatever and
again as i like to say guess what this
is exactly what happens in the world so
you shouldn't be surprised whereas to us
the moral objectivist is incorrect but
they're coming up with some
justification because they also have
moral intuitions right
i've never met a moral objectivist who
used logic and reason to come up with
moral principles that were wildly at
variance with what they wanted the moral
principles to be right
i don't know of anyone who said like
well you know i really think that doing
x is bad i don't like it it repulses me
but i've used logic to say that it is
the right thing and therefore that is
how i will act
generally moral objectivists end up
justifying their moral intuitions just
like constructivists do they just don't
admit it
now i realize that is a highly biased
way of putting it but i'm just letting
you know what my feelings are i'm not
surprised when moral objectivists and
moral constructivists tend to agree but
i do think that it's important and it
matters how you justify these things
because there are gray areas there are
perfectly legitimate questions to which
the answers are not clear
and when that's the case how you justify
your moral principles is more than just
a matter of convenience it can really
make a difference because we don't all
come into life or even develop into
people who have crystal clear perfectly
sensible consistent coherent moral
systems the development of those systems
is an ongoing process and the
justification for it matters
ratboy.exec
says is there a possibility that the
ever-reading and cosmological
multiverses are actually the same thing
meaning could it be that when we conduct
a quantum experiment there is a
proportion of places in the universe in
which the experiment goes one way a
proportion in which it goes the other
and the apparent collapse of the wave
function is really us finding out which
of those kinds of places we're in
um i mean it's it's possible there are
things like that that are true so
that are
that are on the table as maybe being
true let me put it let me put it that
way so but let's distinguish there is an
absolutely a conceptual difference
between the ever-writing and
cosmological multiverse they're
different kinds of things you know deep
down it is possible that in practice
they work out to be similar kinds of
things but also maybe not there's no
necessary connection between them so the
ever-ready and multiverse happens in one
location when i am doing one experiment
one observation of a quantum system
that's in a superposition i measure it
and different outcomes lead to different
universes becoming real there's nothing
there about different locations in space
far away etc etc whereas the
cosmological multiverse is exactly about
different locations in space far away
different things happening the
cosmological multiverse there's no
necessary thing that there is repetition
okay just because if there's me here in
this room that i'm in in santa fe
recording an ama the cosmological
multiverse even if it's infinite does
not imply there's another copy of me or
many copies of me similar to me far away
maybe the laws of physics are just very
different in every one of those
infinitely many other universes okay so
conceptually they're very different
things there was a proposal several
years ago um one paper by yasunori
nomura another by lenny suskin and
raphael busso both of them pointing out
that there is a version of
complementarity
horizon complementarity this is a an
idea that susken and others had in the
context of black holes
that said that if you think about what a
black hole is your description of what
the black hole is is different for
observers who are falling into the black
hole versus looking at it from outside
okay
so from the point of view outside you
think according to this principle that
the black hole really is just like a
membrane at the event horizon there's a
set of degrees of freedom scattered
across the event to rise and you can
count how many they are that's where the
entropy of the black hole comes from
etcetera etcetera and that's really what
it is
and all of this stuff that you learned
in a general relativity course about how
there's nothing at the horizon
from the horizon complementarity point
of view that's what you would see if you
were falling in but it's not how you
describe the black hole from far away so
it's a way of saying that
really all that exists can be summed up
from the point of view of an outside
observer as living at the horizon of a
black hole okay so what does that have
to do with the multiverse if
you apply that same idea but inside out
to cosmology you know we live in a
universe that is accelerating so we're
approaching a de sitter universe kind of
thing that means we have a horizon
around us and we are at the center of
that horizon
and what that might mean maybe who knows
this is just a speculation we're not
sure about any of this stuff what it
might mean is that to us
the entire outside world is equivalent
to a set of degrees of freedom on our
horizon
around us cosmologically and that means
there's only a finite number of
different things that can possibly
in principle be happening in the outside
world
because the entropy of the universe of
the horizon around us is finite okay so
that's very different than this
classical picture where there's an
infinite number of things that can
happen far away so you take that idea
and you combine it with the idea that
there are multiple vacuum states that we
might be able to live in right in string
theory or whatever so multiple
local laws of physics
that you could temporarily have in the
universe and there are transitions
between them via quantum tunneling
and quantum tunneling means branching of
the wave function right going from one
quantum state to another one via
tunneling so the idea is that in this
picture
the whole universe the whole multiverse
is all contained within one horizon size
of a single universe
but the quantum state inside that
horizon is a superposition of different
kinds of vacuum states
so in that sense the whole multiverse is
right here in some sense that's a very
loose sense and it pains me even to say
it because multiverses don't have
locations like that but the idea is that
there's a connection between the
ever-ready and cosmological notion of
multiverse in that picture but no one
knows whether that picture is right
certainly again in principle under
different kinds of laws of physics
you don't need to have any necessary
connection between these two ideas
kevin says do you have any opinions on
working for a few years before applying
for a phd in physics versus applying for
one immediately after graduating
specifically how do universities and
professors view potential phd candidates
with continuous academic experience
versus an interrupted one potentially in
a job that isn't very relevant to
physics either
i think the short answer is it's
absolutely possible
to do something in between undergrad and
grad school other than just continuing
on straight into it but it does not help
your chances so if you think about
applying to grad school as something
that has a chance of success
you don't know it's not 100 it's not
zero percent either in any particular
application process
you can't ever say that you know this or
that will prevent you from going to grad
school or get you in or anything like
that it's all probabilities okay
and my my feeling roughly is that taking
time away from academia lowers your
probability of success it does not make
it zero there's plenty of successful
counter examples to that
but it doesn't help either the
admissions committee for a physics
department is not going to look at your
resume or cv or whatever your
application and say oh yes they spent
three years
doing computer programming or hiking
across europe that's the kind of student
we're looking for just i'm not making
any moral judgments about whether they
should say that but they don't generally
say that okay they like the idea
that you are devoted to
doing nothing but physics that's what
they like uh same thing for eventually
getting tenure right they like the idea
that their junior faculty members are
devoted to doing nothing but physics
research that's what they like to see
and again i'm not making any moral
judgments about what they should like
but uh my advice all else being equal
would be that lowers your chances does
it lower your chances so much that you
can't get in you know not necessarily
that depends on what else is going on on
your application but that's the that's
the sign of the effect anyway
the quintus morvenas says do you like
fantasy books movies tv shows and if so
are you considering meeting g r r martin
there in santa fe uh i do in fact i was
a big fan of the game of thrones series
up until the last season um no plans to
meet gr martin here in santa fe he's not
in santa fe right now i don't think
because i think he was just in the news
for going to san diego comic-con and
getting kovid there so i hope hope he's
okay hope uh g.r martin gets better very
soon because we all want to see those
other books
paul hardy says i read lawrence krauss's
a universe from nothing not sure i'm
understanding it i'm not an expert of
course but it seems as though instead of
proving the universe actually sprung
from no thing at all he just changes the
definition of nothing i always wonder
which is easier to accept stuff came
from no thing at all or stuff has always
existed
so you know i kind of am not that
interested in debates about whether
people change the definitions of things
i don't care what you choose the
definition to be just tell me what the
definition is and then we can decide
what whether that's the question we're
interested in so it's certainly true
that in books like that they don't
really explain why there is something
rather than nothing they don't even try
i mean a lot of the impact there came
from a misappropriation of a quote from
frank wilczak former mindscape guest
frank was working on bariogenesis the
matter anti-matter asymmetry why are
there more particles in the universe
than antiparticles and he proposed a
theory where a symmetric state with
equal numbers of particles and
antiparticles which of course includes
zero
would be unstable
and so the motto is oh there's something
rather than nothing because nothing is
unstable but what frank had in mind
about something in nothing is just
matter particles in the universe versus
no matter particles in the universe but
empty space without matter particles is
not anyone's real idea of nothing
uh or the quantum vacuum or whatever you
want to call it that's not nothing
that's something it's a quantum
mechanical state okay so it's still an
interesting question i mean that's my
point is that what are the interesting
questions and what are the answers to
them okay so
wha how did our universe start
um how did it evolve in the state we see
now that's a very interesting question i
don't think there's any special insights
into it in that book but
it's something that we don't really know
the answer to and would like to know the
answer to it is in my mind a completely
separate question from why the universe
exists at all and i think that there the
whole logic of the question is very very
different
i've written about it if you google why
is there something rather than nothing
you can find my paper
and i tried to make the case that this
is the kind of question that might just
just might not have an answer okay there
is no
such thing as the reason why the
universe exists that's i think is the
most straightforward answer and is that
satisfying or not
i don't know but never promised you a
rose garden no reason why philosophical
questions have to have satisfying
answers they just have to have true
answers
stephen noble says what's your belief on
the existence of innate mathematical
ability is some math just out of reach
for most people like how most people
would never be able to slam dunk or
should we shrink differences in
abilities with better education could we
shrink differences in abilities um well
there's sort of three different
questions here and they they have
implications that i don't necessarily
sign on to so i think it's clear that
innate mathematical ability exists you
know look i love my cats but i have more
innate mathematical ability than them
they're very darling but they are not
very good at solving differential
equations and there's no reason to think
that the same thing shouldn't be true
for human beings as well
i don't think that means that some math
is just out of reach for most people and
maybe it's harder for some people than
others
but i don't think there's any barrier
any phase transition that certain kinds
of math are just out of reach for most
people i think that most people just
don't try or most people aren't educated
uh effectively or whatever if they do
get this opinion that they're not very
good at math i i don't think that we're
very good
at sharing the joys of math widely and
that's one of the reasons why in the new
book series i do all the equations and
i'm sure many people aren't going to
like it you know they're not going to be
interested in it uh you know whenever a
new book comes out you instantly get
these one paragraph reviews from kirkus
and from publishers weekly right and
you're hoping to get you know a good
review uh and you have no idea they're
all anonymous reviews and so the reviews
are out for the biggest ideas in the
universe and the kirkus reviewer really
liked it and the publisher's weekly
reviewer really didn't and it's pretty
clear the publisher's weekly review or
didn't even read the book they just saw
there were a lot of equations they're
like ah i don't like that
and they're going to be people who are
like that you know okay i absolutely
know that but for the people who maybe
are a little bit curious
maybe they're willing to put a little
bit of an effort you know the goal of
the book is to not to force you to read
equations but to allow you
to understand what these equations say
if you want to
and i think that almost everybody
can do it that's why i wrote the book
because if you want to sit down and open
your mind and think about it i'm doing
my best to let you understand the
mathematics behind this and i think that
almost everyone can access it
now the final question could we shrink
differences in abilities with better
education uh
i mean we can certainly increase
everybody's ability whether or not they
will shrink or not i don't know the
differences will shrink or not i don't
know but i think that better education
is certainly possible and important and
could make everybody better at math i'm
all for that
peter blankenheim says do you consider
yourself strongly emergent weekly
emergent a myth or something else so i
do not consider myself a myth
i also do not consider myself strongly
emergent at least not from the
elementary particles of which i made
because i don't think that there is any
strong emergence from elementary
particles i think there's an interesting
question about whether it can be strong
i think that the idea of strong
emergence which by the i mean i've
talked about it before but if a
particular person out there listening
doesn't know
weak emergence is the idea that you can
have some theory of little things right
atoms or molecules or whatever and you
can put them on a computer and find
certain kinds of collective behavior
like solidity of a table or liquidity of
water or something like that no one
thinks that this stuff is violating the
fundamental laws of physics it all
follows from the localized reductionist
interactions between the particles of
which it's made
strong emergence says that if you have a
theory of tiny little pieces and you put
that on a computer there are things that
will happen in nature that are not
predicted that are not compatible with
that kind of explanation that there is
some new ingredient you need over and
above
the simple interactions of local pieces
atoms or particles or whatever to
explain the higher level emergent
phenomena
so my view is that
the existence or not not of strong
emergence depends on the two levels
you're talking about you know there's a
micro or lower level uh a macro or
higher level
if the micro level has entirely local
extremely simple dynamics like we do in
particle physics and quantum field
theory then there's no room for strong
emergence from it unless you think that
the micro level is just wrong which i
don't okay
but if your micro level is like people
and your macro level is society okay
that's a different kind of comparison
between uh you know people make up
society that's another possible case of
emergence
people have interactions with with each
other that are not strictly local and
certainly people's internal states are
not very simple unlike electrons okay
so there maybe i could see the
possibility that you can that there are
things that happen in collective
behavior of people
that you can't quite capture in any
particular simple theory of individual
people interacting with each other
one-on-one
okay
i'm not sure that that's true i'm just
trying to be open-minded about it i
think that it's not as clear in that
case as it is the absence of strong
emergence in the atoms and particles
case so if you think about myself being
emergent from atoms and particles that
would be weak emergence not strong
emergence
sunnis mended says given the very real
possibility that the us will cease to be
a functioning democracy in the near
future what if any specific steps are
you taking to prepare for what comes
next have you thought about fleeing to a
different country beefed up emergency
preparedness etc
um roughly speaking no i've not thought
about any of those things you know look
even if i think i agree that there is a
non-trivial chance that the u.s will
cease to be functioning democracy um
what does non-trivial mean in this case
i don't know
but it's enough that
whereas 20 years ago i would not have
considered the possibility seriously i
think that right now you do have to
consider the possibility seriously
but
i think there's a big difference between
not being a functioning democracy and
riots on the streets and mobs burning
down houses okay those are not the same
thing
there's plenty of monarchies
where
the actual day-to-day life is pretty
simple and straightforward maybe you
lack some freedom to get on the internet
or say what you want but you still on a
day-to-day level live your life
um
so i'm very you know cognizant of the
possibility that that's what happens
look if
the republican party manages to
undermine the way that elections are
held and decides that their state
legislatures can just make up who they
think the winner is no matter what the
actual voting outcome was we will have
effectively gotten rid of democracy in
the united states but i can imagine that
for many people life just goes on as
usual it would be worse for some people
but it would be kind of like republicans
are in power the real difference is they
will never go out of power once that
happens i think that would be terrible
but my
immediate
plan would be to stay here and fight it
to fight it you know not using guns and
pitchforks but using ideas and and uh
persuasion as much as i can to try to
get people to appreciate that this is
not how things should be and uh maybe
things you know there's also the
possibility that things are much more
dramatically worse and
uh more drastic steps will be taken but
i don't think that's the most likely
outcome right here
okay now i'm going to group together a
bunch of questions um you'll see what
the common topic is eric stromfist says
what outstanding questions in cosmology
or astrophysics do you expect are likely
to be answered by data from the webb
space telescope now that it has become
operational
andrew goldstein says is it possible
that jwst's ability to see further back
in time and with greater resolution
could expand our understanding of
quantum mechanics sheldon silliman says
my question is about the potential of
jwst to advance our knowledge of the
quantum world will obtaining information
about the relative chemical compositions
of early galaxies provide new
information relevant to the big bang or
inflation models
and sam hartzog says i was thrilled to
see the first images from jwst that got
me thinking about what might be in the
realm of space telescopes two or three
decades down the road in spherical cow
units there's two orders of magnitude
between the maximum detectable
wavelength of the jwst and the cosmic
microwave background wavelength how much
juicy scientific goodness do you think
we might ring out of the gap between the
two so first a footnote uh sheldon
sillyman uh asked a question last month
and i i guessed that that was a
pseudonym but it was not so i i honestly
and sincerely apologize sheldon for that
i mean obviously from some of the
names i've read previously in this ama
we do get pseudonyms here and that's
perfectly okay but i shouldn't presume
that someone's name is a is a pseudonym
just because it could have been and i'm
sorry about that i i really do apologize
sorry
um but for these questions you know
let me give a sort of big picture answer
because there's a lot of similarity here
and then i'll try to be a little bit
more fine-grained
jwst is an amazing instrument
that will teach us a lot about science
there are plenty of questions in science
that are not questions of fundamental
physics or the origin of the universe
jwst is not meant to tell us about the
nature of quantum mechanics the origin
of the universe what happened at the big
bang or anything like that the two main
science goals are
the early galaxy formation history of
the universe
and
exoplanets planets around other stars
right like we talked about with john
johnson recently
because jwst is an infrared telescope
which means number one it can see sort
of glowy light from planets and things
like that and number two it can see
galaxies in their early formation period
because the light from them is
redshifted by a lot so an infrared
telescope is very helpful there and of
course just the resolution of the
telescope is is enormously good um
so the kind of astrophysics that we're
learning about
is well described by the standard model
of particle physics and general
relativity there's almost no reason to
think that we will learn about new
fundamental physics from jwst
and that's okay
most interesting physics is not
fundamental physics most interesting
physics is plenty compatible with the
standard model and general relativity
and quantum mechanics as we know it okay
so it's still really really interesting
to think about how galaxies form how
stars form uh how black holes form at
the center of galaxies how the planets
are distributed around stars in our
galaxy what the nature of those planets
are and their atmospheres all these are
really really interesting questions none
of them have anything to do with with
quantum mechanics at a fundamental level
or general relativity or anything like
that i mean what i mean by that is of
course quantum mechanics and general
relativity are involved in them but
there's no real chance you could always
be surprised but there's no real
prospect that you're going to modify our
understanding of quantum mechanics or
general relativity on the basis of that
likewise for the big bang or inflation
or whatever there's much better ways to
get information about what happened near
the big bang than there is jwst because
you know telescopes like jwst have
narrow
relatively narrow fields of view right
you're trying to focus in on a galaxy or
a cluster of galaxies or something like
that
most of the interesting information
about inflation has to do with the
spectrum of perturbations of density in
the early universe for which you want to
look at the most universe that you
possibly can that's why things like wmap
and plunk do all sky surveys it's sort
of the complement of what something like
jwst does
and for sam's question about the gap in
between jwst's wavelengths and the cmb
well
yeah there is something called radio
telescopes they do that all the time
wavelengths longer than infrared are in
the get it get to be in the microwave
and radio regime and there's a really
really nice feature of that regime
namely that our atmosphere is largely
transparent to it
so you can look at it without going into
space our atmosphere absorbs infrared
light
which is causing the greenhouse effect
you may have been locally affected by
this fact uh very recently that's why to
see it you have to put a telescope out
there in space but to see radio waves
you can just do it right here on earth
now
you can do it better and more precisely
out in space which is why wmap and
planck were satellites because if you
want to do an all sky survey at a very
very low temperature it does help to go
to space okay that's what the microwave
background uh satellites do but there's
very very effective microwave background
observations going on here on earth at
the south pole in chile and elsewhere
you can easily look at small patches of
the cmb sky right here on earth no
problem likewise the space telescope the
hubble space telescope was looking at
visible light which does pass through
the earth but it's more clear if you're
out there in space but if you're down
here on earth there's still lots of very
very useful interesting
visible wavelength astronomy going on
okay so we're definitely looking in that
gap using good old-fashioned radio
telescopes
sean miller says if biological systems
maintain homeostasis
by minimizing the delta between what's
expected and what is perceived and this
delta is driven by probability
distributions tied to vital interests
how is this biological computation
different from computation that is
maintaining homeostasis but is not tied
to vital interests to put it another way
what is the difference between
biological perception and non-biological
perception well if i if i'm
understanding this question correctly um
it's an interesting issue but it's
somewhat philosophical i think that at
the scientific slash
technical level there's no difference
between biological perception and
non-biological perception in both cases
you have detectors in some sense
interacting with the rest of the world
in a way that conveys information about
the outside world to the system doing
the detecting the question is what do
you do with that information that you've
detected and what is the purpose for
which you are detecting it and just
letting the word purpose seek into you
seep into your discussion there is
already uh tilting the scales a little
bit right when do things have purposes
so i don't know if we talked about i
think maybe we did but uh the interview
with dan dennett here on the podcast
touch on a lot of interesting things and
one of dan's big ideas is what he calls
the intentional stance
which is when you assign
intent
purposes goals to a system okay
and his idea and i'm not sure i'm i'm
not an expert on this so but i'm just
clueing you in on the idea if you want
to read more about him become an expert
yourself but the idea of someone like
dan is look people are physical systems
just like robots are or computers or
other parts of the world
sometimes it is useful and illuminating
to talk about these physical systems as
if they have intense
uh intense in the you know i intend to
do this or intend to do that not that
they're intense about their intentions i
suppose i should say they have
intentions um so we talk we take a
stance towards something that attributes
to it goals purposes intentions
whatsoever why well because that gives
us insight because it's a useful
description it's like why do we
attribute temperature or pressure to a
fluid even though we could just talk
about the individual molecules well
because it's a description that gives us
information that is useful and can be
made to make predictions it can be used
to make predictions etc likewise if i
say oh that person intends to shoot me
that has conveyed very interesting and
important information
that would be less usefully conveyed by
just listing the state of all the
neurons in their brains okay
and if you think that that's what's
going on then you should be asking well
when does it become useful
to attach intentionality to physical
systems that are not biological systems
and the answer is
i don't know
i mean it could in principle be very
complicated i mean there's again there's
this sort of metaphilosophical question
what is going on is there something that
is an essence of intentionality or you
know biological desire to maintain
homeostasis that is different at a deep
ontological level then the
fact that a thermostat maintains your
house at the right temperature and i
think that dan dennett and i would say
no there's no deep
essential difference at the ontological
level there but you don't need you're
not you don't add anything to a
discussion of the thermostat by saying
oh it intends or it wants or it desires
to keep your house at the right
temperature whereas you do get some
insight in talking about a complex
system like a person in in talking that
way so there will be some crossover from
one to the other it might be subtle and
unclear when you do it that's a good
thing to talk about but i think the
underlying philosophical question
is more or less answered by that kind of
attitude
andrew jaffe says what are your thoughts
on idealism when do you consider
when you consider a material explanation
for the universe it's difficult to
comprehend exactly where our space
exists relative to other possible spaces
could it in fact be as ideal as may
contend much like a dream where the
actual space of the dream is in someone
else's head in bed
i attach almost zero credence to
idealism idealism for those out there
who have avoided this fortunately in
their lives
idealism might be opposed to materialism
or dualism as a as a theory of the
relationship of the mind to the physical
world okay
a dualist thinks that there is something
mind like
something world and matter like and they
interact somehow
a materialist think there's things
there's just the physical material world
and the mind is sort of an emergent
thing that comes out of that whereas an
idealist thinks that there's only the
mind and the physical world is just a
way of mind or minds there's different
versions of idealism but a way of mind
sort of organizing their thoughts about
the world okay
and to me that has zero
pull as a fundamental view of reality
and not for very sophisticated reasons
for like the most basic obvious reasons
namely it certainly seems like different
minds construct more or less the same
physical world
like my friends don't have different
ideas about what the laws of physics are
than i do why is that and i'm sure that
a good idealist can come up with
perfectly reasonable reasons why it's
like that but i have an even better
reason why namely because there really
is a physical world out there and i also
think that once you understand the
physical world and how it works it's
very natural that things like minds
would arise within it so i don't really
think that uh idealism is in any sense
attractive there's plenty of work to be
done in understanding materialism and
physicalism
andreas kelly says what's your favorite
movie that doesn't have anything to do
with science or science fiction uh well
many of my favorite movies have nothing
to do with science and science fiction
probably my favorite movie is casablanca
i know it's not very
uh original i'm not being very clever
here saying that casablanca and pride
and prejudice are my favorite
uh stories ever but you know they're
they're classics for a reason and i
think that uh i these are things i can
just go back to over and over again
i almost said brazil which is another
favorite movie of mine but i realized
that that's probably science fiction
isn't it it probably counts as science
fiction but so let's just go with
casablanca
i would easily take you know depending
on the mood right i would take uh the
sting as another example of a movie that
i could just watch over and over again
michael schillingford says in a
naturalistic context there
are many sensationalistic claims that
frequently draw a lot of attention in
science journalism the word illusion is
a word frequently tossed out with regard
to just about anything we deal with in
our daily life whether it be chairs
consciousness colors do you think
sensational claims and
hyper-reductionism vocabulary play a
larger role in why some reject
naturalism
so i'm not 100 sure i i'm appreciating
the question here but i think what
you're saying is
that there are people who claim or are
naturalists that is to say they think
that there's only one world the natural
world there's no extra supernatural
world and those people sometimes refer
to things that we know and love like
chairs consciousness colors as illusions
um that is and you're wondering whether
or not this
uh is overly sensational so i don't
it doesn't really affect my feeling
about them to think that they're overly
sensational i think that people who make
those claims are generally just trying
their best they're trying to understand
how the world works you know someone who
works on cosmology and quantum mechanics
and relativity i am well aware that
doing our best to understand how the
world works can lead us to making
statements that to someone who hasn't
studied these things seem bizarre and
way out and sensational right but if we
think they're true we should make them
anyway so i the
charge of overly sensationalizing things
is not a very one that i worry about too
much now i also don't agree that it
makes sense to talk about these things
as illusions to me
when you say something is an illusion
it's a trick
it's giving people the impression that
something is there when it's really not
and i think that things like
consciousness and free will and chairs
are there
they are not illusions okay now i i know
what they mean um what they mean is that
they don't these things chairs or free
will or whatever don't have fundamental
essences they really just mean they're
emergent that's really what they mean
but i don't want to attach the word
illusion to emergent things i think
immersion things are just as real why
because they give us a handle on reality
because they help us understand what is
going on and make predictions that's the
criterion for being real like if you
are starving in a desert
and you think you see an oasis and it's
just an illusion
that does not give you a useful handle
on reality that will cause you to crawl
toward that uh oasis and you would be
wrong okay so that's an illusion you're
actually being tricked and thinking that
it's there is hurting you in your
attempts to make it through the day and
understand the world whereas
chairs and consciousness and colors i
think help you get through the world get
through the day
paul hess says does dark energy deserve
to be part of the pie chart of the
composition of our universe along with
dark matter and baryonic manner it seems
very different from the other two forms
of matter
the amount of it doesn't seem to be
conserved as space expands and it
doesn't seem to be interchangeable with
matter if it turns out to be
cosmological constant is it even an
energy at all so the answer is yes it is
an energy
sorry you asked two different versions
of the question it does deserve to be
part of the pie chart yes it really is
an energy in a very very specific sense
that sense is we have an equation for
the evolution of the universe the
friedman equation um derived by uh
alexander friedman
soon after einstein invented general
relativity and the friedman equation so
part of general relativity it relates
the expansion rate of the universe to
the amount of energy in the universe h
squared is proportional to rho where h
is the hubble parameter and rho is the
energy density and if you want to fit
the data you better do what general
relativity tells you to do which is that
into that expression for the energy
density you better put matter and
radiation and the vacuum energy the dark
energy they better all be there okay
and the reasons that you're giving uh to
maybe be suspicious don't actually
really hold up so you say the amount of
it doesn't seem to be conserved as space
expands
true
but same thing is true for radiation the
energy and radiation goes down as space
expands and we still need to count that
as energy and then you say it doesn't
seem to be interchangeable with matter
but that's not true if you believe in
inflation or false vacuum states or
anything like that there are very
straightforward physical mechanisms that
convert dark energy into ordinary matter
and radiation so yeah by all
ways that we have a thinking about what
should count as energy dark energy
should count
bits plus atoms says given that we don't
live in anti-descender space why do many
scientists believe the adscft
correspondence is so important to
understanding quantum gravity in other
world in other words what provides the
hint that adscft may generalize well the
way that i like to put it is
if in my more cynical moments you know
the old story of the drunk guy looking
for his keys under the lamp post and a
guy tries to help him and says i don't
see him anywhere you sure this is where
you drop them and he says no i dropped
them somewhere else but the light is
really good over here
so ads cft is the world's brightest lamp
post when it comes to quantum gravity
the point being that we understand ads
cft it's a it's a known model at least
in a way that is much much more precise
and spelled out than we have models of
quantum gravity in other cases so it's
not that we have good reason to think
that ads cft will generalize we have
reasons to hope it will let's put it
that way but that's different than a
good reason to think it will what we
have is the ability to ask questions and
answer them and that's just incredibly
valuable right you can get wisdom you
can learn things about the general way
things work by having solvable models
even if those solvable models do not
extend directly to the real world it's
again the spherical cow philosophy and i
i would
understand and maybe even be sympathetic
to people who say that we spend too much
time thinking about ads cft because
you know physicists get happy when there
are equations they can solve right
they're less happy when they are
struggling with ideas and not sure what
equations to put down to paper their
happiest when there are equations that
they can write down put into different
contexts get out solutions and that's
the case in ads cft it's not the world
okay but what you're hoping is you get
some wisdom about how quantum gravity
works in this one case where you think
you know how quantum gravity works
it doesn't seem to make sense to say
well
i would rather have zero cases where
quantum gravity works at least you have
this one so i think that it makes
absolute sense to put a lot of effort
into ads cfd i just don't think that it
should be the only thing you put effort
into you really need to and many people
do try to push beyond into other
contexts
tyler ogirec says feel free to pass on
this question if it's too personal but
what drove you and jennifer's decision
not to have any children was it the plan
from day one just to be the two of you
or was this a decision that was reached
over time what is older married life
without children like
older married life you know i i noticed
you sneaked the word older in there and
i will let you get away with this this
time i certainly am older than i used to
be i guess uh but older married life
without children is awesome i love it
and look i love other people having
children too so
there are personal aspects to questions
like this which we can set aside but
there are also big picture ethical moral
social questions right is there some
moral obligation to either have or not
have children
and i think roughly the answer is no you
know i think that there are people who
claim that there is but i find their
arguments entirely unpersuasive so our
decision to not have children was uh
something that we always had it was just
always our personal preference it was
not like
either uh something that was forced upon
us by circumstance nor was it some
kind of big picture moral social stance
it's just that neither one of us wanted
kids we had other things to do
and we're doing them and we're very very
very busy doing them and you know having
kids is a lot of work and there's a lot
of benefits to having kids and a lot of
downside and there's a balance and
everyone should make that balance
individually i don't think there's any
obligations big pictures socially either
way
emmett francis says i finally went back
and listened to your first mind chat
with philip goff and keith frankish that
was a someone else's podcast i did
either on youtube or audio with philip
goffin and heath frankish about
consciousness and so emmett saying one
follow-up question could there be a type
of consciousness that has no causal
influence but still matters in some
sense to use a crude metaphor maybe
consciousness is more like someone
watching a movie the observer has no
causal influence over the effects on the
screen but over the events on the screen
but it still matters that there is
someone there doing the observing
perhaps
well i mean there could be things like
that i suppose that sounds nothing at
all like the consciousness that i know
and love a part of our consciousness is
absolutely
related to how we act in the world of
course you can imagine people who might
be paralyzed or somehow disabled to the
extent that they cannot act in the world
and still be conscious that's right but
if you have the ability to act and you
are conscious i think that those are
related to each other so i'm not sure i
mean you can imagine things like what
you're suggesting but i'm not sure if it
sheds any light or is relevant to the
questions that philip and keith and i
were talking about which is trying to
come to a better understanding of the
good old consciousness that we know and
love
herb berkowitz says there is an earlier
controversy about whether the web
telescope's name should be changed
because of allegations relating to
alleged behavior of james webb vis-a-vis
members of the gay community nasa
decided to leave the name of the
telescope unchanged but now the
controversy seems to be flaring up again
what is your take on this specific
dispute
so i guess there's the sort of big
picture question here and the specific
question the specific question being
james webb himself the bigger picture
question about what do we do when we
realize the people who we are honoring
by naming things after them are less
good people than we thought
so about james webb i'm not an expert
i'm not a super duper follower of the
give and take about people trying to
investigate this from what i have read
on both sides it seems that he was
pretty involved in
there was a set of episodes back in i
guess the 50s and 60s where gay people
were sought out and purged from the
federal government or from certain
agencies thereof and webb seems to have
been not the boss of that
but going along with it and abetting it
as far as i can tell it's hard to tell
sometimes because people were cagey
about what they wrote down and so forth
um but also you know
those telescope never should have been
named after james webb that was a bad
idea james webb is not a scientist um
there is a difference between
parenthetically this is a slightly
different issue but there's a difference
between using a name as just a label or
almost a citation right schrodinger
erwin schroedinger is uh under current
discussion about whether or not he was a
pedophile whether or not he liked young
girls younger than what we would now
consider the age of consent and i don't
think there's any reason to rename even
if it's all true no reason to rename
schrodinger's equation anything else
because he didn't invent the equation
right it's not like we're honoring him
that's not the point of calling it
schrodinger's equation we're just
mentioning the historical fact that he
wrote it down first whereas james webb
did not invent this james webb space
telescope it was specifically meant to
be honoring him but he was not a
scientist he was an administrator at
nasa and other places and the importance
of administrators at nasa and other
places is very very high like i do not
want to say that it all could have
happened without them there's absolutely
a role being played there but i
preferred it back when telescopes were
named after people like hubble and
chandra and so forth fermi scientists
who are really using this kind of data
to understand the world better so i
leave it to others to judge the
specifics of the biography of james webb
but if it is true that he was involved
in that kind of behavior then i'm
completely in favor of changing the name
even if it costs a little bit of money
lewis i should say let me before going
to lewis's question uh you know one of
the points of this is
you could say look who cares there are
people who are the general public who
are interested in the science coming out
of jwst they don't know the biography of
this guy
what difference does it make and the
difference it makes is that there are
people who are gay or otherwise
in various kind of minority groups that
have historically been discriminated
against
who take this as a message and
rightfully so the message being we don't
care about you or your feelings right
and again this is all conditionalized on
whether or not you do think that james
webb was involved in this but if you do
then i think it's pretty clear that you
should take action to not let this kind
of thing happen and even if it is
difficult to rename the telescope it is
worth it trying to you know send the
message that these people do matter that
people who might be different than the
standard 1950s nuclear family ideal are
nevertheless human beings with the same
rights and dignities as everybody else
and they haven't always been treated
that way and it's important to do what
we can to fix that and this if it's
possible to do so by things like this
then let's do it
it wouldn't fix everything obviously but
it might be a nice gesture in that
direction that we at least are trying to
make things better
okay louis your final your question gets
finally answered louis wawaru says what
is a belief you once held that has
changed during your adulthood and would
you reflect on what it was like if you
can for example was it a matter of being
wrong or naive the longer-held the most
recent if that needs a selector uh yeah
i mean i change all sorts of beliefs
uh the obvious things to change are
scientific beliefs when there's just new
data that comes in i used to believe the
cosmos constant was zero now i don't
uh there's also more you know
science-related beliefs but nevertheless
judgment calls like i used to be in the
crowd that objected
to kicking pluto out of the solar system
planet club i mean
pluto is still in the solar system but
now's the dwarf planet not a planet and
my argument was that look we made up the
word planet right we can make it up to
be whatever we want and we can always
grandfather in pluto even if we come up
with a definition for the word planet
that is consistently plied applied uh
going forward when we discovered new
planets around other star systems that
doesn't mean we couldn't just
grandfather in pluto and say like it's
an honorary planet or something like
that
but after you know having mike brown on
the podcast and reading his book and
talking to other people and thinking
about it i do get it i get why it was
useful to rename it uh to relabel pluto
and it's not that pluto changed
obviously is that we understood more
about what kinds of objects there are in
the solar system and elsewhere
and you know the argument that i liked
the best was from mike brown who said
you know look if
things like pluto count as planets then
he mike would be the greatest planet
discoverer of all time because he's
found various other dwarf planets out
there at the edges of the solar system
but they don't those other guys don't
really deserve planet status and
therefore pluto does not and there is
something to be said for scientific
consistency on questions like this um
that's a very a relatively recent one
you know other kinds of non-scientific
things i i used to be a moral
objectivist i used to think that there
was a science of morality and you could
derive true statements about right and
wrong from
is statements about you know
evolutionary biology and and what people
want to do and things like that and it
was just an improved philosophical
understanding that let me realize that
that was not going to happen
wei lee woon says concepts like the
block universe arrow of time multiverse
have profoundly changed how i view the
world for example fully embracing the
block universe view could allow one to
take a more philosophical view when
dealing with life's challenges or
personal
tragedy in a similar sense do you feel
that your deep knowledge of physics has
changed your approach to life and more
importantly are there concrete examples
of how being a theoretical physicist has
guided your everyday actions
i think the most honest answer here is
no
i can't think of anything specifically
that is a way that i act or feel that
would be radically different if i knew
less physics i think you know the honest
answer if the honest answer to this were
yes i would have to be able to come up
with an example of some way that i got
through life that just wouldn't have
been available to me without knowing
physics i can't honestly think of that
now having said that i'm sure
that knowledge of physics has seeped
into various beliefs and ways of living
that i have in ways that i don't even
know about right
certainly the biggest one is the absence
of god in the world which is related to
scientific understanding in various ways
and that's why you know with my friends
who are scientists and philosophers who
don't like talking about god who are
atheists right but think that it gets in
the way of talking about science when we
talk about religion i think that's a
mistake because
there isn't any other more direct
relationship between our scientific
understanding and the meaning of life
than to decide whether or not god exists
you know whether or not god exists is an
important question
and science bears on that question and
so i think we should talk about it on
one side or the other i think that
non-atheist scientists should also talk
about it but anyway
i i don't think that you need know a lot
of science to become an atheist or to
believe that life's purpose is something
you generate for yourself rather than
being imposed from elsewhere so i don't
think there's a very close connection
there
arnie moskowitz says it is generally
agreed that a regular amount of physical
exercise is not only essential to
maintain health but is believed that
increasing the blood flow to the brain
will actually improve intellectual
output so i'm afraid to ask what is your
exercise routine uh i'm not actually up
on the evidence one way or the other
about physical exercise and intellectual
output but it's a very plausible story
so i'm not gonna deny it it's it's very
believable
that you know so there's a joke that
went around i'm not even sure if it's a
true story or just made up but
a graduate student uh was you know kind
of pooh-poohing the need for exercise or
physical activity and their advisor says
what are you a dualist
about the mind and the body and they say
no i know what i'm definitely just a
physical list and then well then the
mind comes from the body and then you
want to keep your body in good shape
and again that's not a scientific
hypothesis that has been rigorously
tested uh but it makes perfect sense and
there is of course some evidence for it
so therefore
i do think it's important to exercise
and i don't do as much as i should but i
do try to exercise jennifer my wife is
is an exercise um
aficionado fanatic i don't know what the
right word is a regular she exercises
all the time she has a black belt in jiu
jitsu
and
she's never told me that i need to
exercise myself but i do exercise myself
sometimes and she inspires me to try to
do better let's put it that way
so i try to actually go to a gym or
something like that a couple times a
week when you're traveling or when
you're moving across country that
becomes very very hard
there is an app that i found that is
kind of fun called seven like the number
seven i'm not getting any money from it
not advertising it but it's just a
simple uh seven minute it's really eight
minute exercise routine you can do in
your hotel room right there's no
weights or equipment involved and so and
if you want to you can do it two or
three or four times in a row if you're
feeling that energetic that's not a lot
of exercise obviously less than 10
minutes but getting the blood flowing
just a little bit is uh helpful you know
i did i have recently switched to
standing desks that i can move up and
down so i can sit or stand at my desk i
like the fact that i can do either one
otherwise i would just be sitting down
all the time when i am actually at the
gym it's just a mismatch of of different
things i do some cardio lifting weights
various flexibility yoga type things
when i'm in the vicinity of a good yoga
place i will go to yoga classes also and
because sitting down for long periods of
time typing at the computer is just not
what the human body was meant to do and
yoga is almost as if it were invented to
make up for the strains you put on your
body when you do that kind of thing so i
highly recommend it
jacob arkhan says in episode 9 on the
solo episode and why is there something
rather than nothing regarding your early
interest and big ideas you said when i
forgot by the way yes and we recently
just we just were talking about that
weren't we in the ama that i mentioned
that i wrote a paper on that it is also
true that i did a solo podcast on it so
if you're more audio friendly than uh
text friendly check out the podcast on
that anyway jacob says
that i said quote when i would fall
asleep at night thinking about something
that i've read in a cosmology book or
whatever at some point my brain would
come onto this question of what if i
weren't even here what if the universe
was not here what then and then that was
it no more sleep for me that night that
was the kind of thing that kept me up at
night that and bigfoot but that's a
whole nother story so what's the story
about bigfoot
jacob asks all right this is how much i
appreciate you all out there in patreon
and podcast land uh helping me with the
uh donations and leading to the amas
that i will tell you the bigfoot story
which is that we were moving from a tiny
apartment to a not very large uh you
know suburban house in pennsylvania and
i was like
eight nine ten something like that at
that kind of age okay
and uh i had a younger brother and so
for the first time in our lives we're
gonna get separate bedrooms this was
very exciting because we used to you
know when we were younger we would just
have bunk beds in the same room
and as the slightly older brother i get
to choose which bedroom i was going to
get and there were basically
two choices there was a well there were
three choices there was a relatively
large bedroom relatively small bedroom
both upstairs with the other bedrooms
but there was also a sort of a den
downstairs that could be used as a
bedroom okay
and
the obvious sensible thing would have
been to just to go for the larger
bedroom upstairs where all the bedrooms
were but i thought it would be you know
cooler to be far away from everybody
else and have my privacy and therefore i
went for the den downstairs and
converted that into my bedroom
and within weeks after we had moved
we
i think i forget whether we actually
went to the movie theater or i just saw
it on tv but i saw a
documentary i hesitate to call it a
documentary but it was about bigfoot uh
and it was you know a pretty credulous
documentary basically making the case
that bigfoot was probably real there was
all this grainy footage and reenactments
and for my nine-year-old or whatever
self that was really scary even though
it wasn't meant to be scary he was meant
to just be ooh look bigfoot and bigfoot
is also just not that scary right but it
wasn't you know science fiction or
fantasy it was something that was
plausibly real and so my subconscious
reacted badly to the existence of
bigfoot and
being alone downstairs in the house all
by myself uh on the first floor of our
suburban house i could you know look
outside and see trees and hear noises
that i couldn't recognize and i became
afraid that bigfoot was going to be
outside now i was even at that age i was
perfectly rational enough to know that
that was completely silly bigfoot didn't
exist and if bigfoot did exist he would
not be trundling around the suburbs of
philadelphia in pennsylvania
nevertheless there's a part of your
brain that is not the logical rational
part and it i just didn't want to stay
downstairs all by myself anymore so i
moved back upstairs but of course by
that time i lost the good bedroom and so
i was stuck for the next whatever years
before i graduated until i graduated
high school in the smaller bedroom
upstairs there's a lesson there of some
sort but i'm not exactly sure what it is
matt rappaport says
recently i was listening to a science
podcast that seemed to suggest there are
a number of cracks forming in the
standard model they cited three findings
number one mass of the w boson number
two magnetic properties of muons number
three excess production of heavier
quarks than predicting the standard
model
do you think that experimental data is
beginning to show cracks in the standard
model
well you know i don't know i think that
all these three examples are different i
mean there's another
one that i think you're not
mentioning
[Music]
i think you're not mentioning it anyway
remember i did a solo podcast a little
while ago about the muons in particular
because you're mentioning one muon
experiment the one at fermilab with the
magnetic moment there's also
an experiment i think at the lhc
on the decay of the muons violating
flavor universality like while acting
differently uh to with respect to
different flavors of particles that it's
decaying into and i think that those are
relatively respectable anomalies so just
so you know sort of how to think about
these things
there are always anomalies you know we
do many many experiments if you do 100
experiments you expect to see a 1 in 100
anomaly sometimes right
and of course you then begin to study
that particular anomaly more closely et
cetera et cetera and people get excited
and they write papers about what it
could be and et cetera et cetera so the
very fact that there are anomalies does
not by itself make me think that there
are cracks in the standard model there
always were and always will be anomalies
they have to become really really strong
for me to get excited about them in the
muon case in particular
probably the strongest anomaly in the
sense of
disagreement between theory and
experiment seems to be the magnetic
moment of the muon in a believable way
the w boson mass i'm not that excited
about because it's incompatible with
other measurements including
measurements by the same detector in
earlier years and it's based on
ten-year-old data et cetera et cetera it
could be true
could be i mean the people who are doing
it are good people good physicists but
it's hard to do that and when it doesn't
fit in together with other experiments
then
your your guess is that they're just
missing something right it might not be
true but that's a guess whereas the the
magnetic moment of the muon seems to be
pretty solid except then you read the
fine print and what you find is that
there is a calculation regard with
regard to what the magnetic moment of
the muon should be
that involves qcd the strong
interactions which is always very very
hard to calculate in and they do the
best they can and they get this
discrepancy but there is an alternative
way of calculating that that makes the
discrepancy go away
and that you know it's always just the
safer bet to think the discrepancy is
going to go away eventually some
discrepancy will not go away but i don't
think that any of these discrepancies
are quite strong enough that i would bet
at 50 50 that they're going to last but
we have to do more experiments collect
better data and then we'll know
lester sue says one of the questions
from your last ama regarding democracy
and course correction got me wondering
are societies that place more value on
stability particularly those with
autocratic governments more prone to
instability in the long run have you
considered this or are you aware of any
research considering this and in
particular do you think there might be
similar physical systems that one can
draw useful comparisons with
uh so no i've not considered it and i
don't know of anyone who's considered
that but
it seems to be a very difficult question
to ask all by itself you know the number
of societies that have existed in
history
is not that large compared to the number
of events we see the large hadron
collider or something like that and you
could try to compare the long-term
stability of dictatorships versus
democracies but not only is there very
little data but there's so many other
factors that matter right the democracy
in athens is very different than the
democracy in rome which is very
different than the democracy that the
iroquois had which is very different
than the democracy we have here in the
united states for all sorts of reasons
so i would just be skeptical that you
could focus in on that one variable and
draw any close comparisons
jake cornigay says whenever i see a
physicist describe what would happen if
a person were to fall into a black hole
they always talk about spaghettification
or how you wouldn't even know you'd
cross the event horizon in the case of
supermassive black holes i understand
simplifying things for the audience but
what would really happen to a person
entering a black hole in a spacesuit
with tidal forces strong enough to pull
the person apart near the event horizon
kill them by exposure to space as the
suit ripped apart or would
spaghettification stretch the person in
suit together such that the person would
live long enough to experience a painful
demise from the spaghettification
well uh i don't know as sure as the
short answer there's an engineering
question here about the tactile strength
in your spacesuit and things like that
which i am completely ignorant about but
i do know you know the prediction from
classical general relativity of what
would happen in the black hole the point
of the spaghettification talk is that it
doesn't happen near the event horizon
that's not where it happens it happens
when you approach the singularity if the
black hole is small and again the
singularity is a point in your future so
that's okay you can still approach it
you just approach it in time
if the singular if the black hole is
small the singularity is close all the
time and you know as soon as you get to
the event horizon you're already close
to the event or to the singularity and
there can be spaghettification the point
of spaghettification is any object is
pulled in one direction the direction
that is sort of pointing inside the
black hole and squeezed in the other two
directions so it is differentially torn
apart and that happens to both you and
your spacesuit equally okay so then
there is a question about you know does
the spacesuit hold up like if the
spacesuit stretches by 20 percent maybe
it still
maintains its air tightness but if you
stretch by 20 i suspect you die right
but maybe i don't know maybe your
spacesuit is weaker than you are and
your your boots fall off before you get
stretched so much that you die and
therefore you would die from the loss of
air i don't know the details what i do
know is when you approach the
singularity you get stretched that's the
spaghettification
joss charles says after listening to the
wonderful quantum steampunk episode i
went and got the book near the end there
was a discussion that seemed to connect
the uncertainty principle with the
second law of thermodynamics am i right
that there is a connection between these
things and does this mean that there
could be a sense in which the
uncertainty principle leads to the arrow
of time
well
there's a connection
but there's not a necessary or a strong
connection let's put it that way i mean
the second law of thermodynamics was
invented long before quantum mechanics
was right boltzmann understood the
second law of quantum thermodynamics
without knowing anything about the
uncertainty principle and usually when
we do a textbook
explanation of the second law or the
kind of explanation like i did in my
book from eternity to here
it's all perfectly classical there's
nothing in there about
the uncertainty principle or any other
quantum mechanical effect
of course the world is quantum the world
is not classical so all those
discussions are merely
approximations to what really happens
and i think that the relevant thing to
say is that when you are in the regime
where quantum effects are important then
you can have a relationship between the
uncertainty principle and the second law
but when you're mixing cream into coffee
you're not in that regime there's no
importance in
quantum effects or the uncertainty
principle or anything like that and you
know by the way i say this over and over
again but the arrow of time is explained
it is explained by the definition that
we have of entropy from boltzmann and
the fact that the entropy in the early
universe was low those two things
together explain the arrow of time what
we don't have explained is why the
entropy of the universe was low and i
don't see any direct connection between
that and the uncertainty principle
bart connolly says i have a question
about materialism i've noticed that
statements made by materialists usually
include the word just as in synonym for
mere or insignificant yet if you remove
that word from such statements as humans
are just robots made of chemicals you
get a much more profound and even
pantheistic statement humans are robots
made of chemicals my favorite is of
course we are just the universe
observing itself which i really prefer
to be we are the universe observing
itself i'm not throwing proverbial shade
on materialists as i often agree with
them rather i just think as it were the
materialist statements are a lot more
positive once you remove that silly word
what do you think
yeah i'm i'm somewhat sympathetic to
this uh i get it you know the the
meaning
is the same either way you know i always
i think back not always i shouldn't say
that but julia galliff who was a former
podcast guest
she had a very good tweet a while back
where she says when she's reading news
articles
and she has sees someone quoted as
saying you know professor x
admits blank she always in her minds
translates admits to says
because it's the same
substantive content the person made this
statement but it's not trying to put
some kind of normative or evaluative
spin on it and that lets you decide for
yourself how to judge the words coming
out of someone's mouth and i like that
because i've been
uh
that's been done to me like i've said
things like we don't know how the
universe began and i'm quoted as saying
carol admits that we don't know how the
universe began i'm like well it wasn't
much of an admission i wasn't you know
trying to hide the fact i say that all
the time
likewise the word just in these
sentences isn't adding any extra
substance right i think bart you're
completely correct you could just take
it out and you'd be just as it were as
correct
but i get why people add it there also
because it is a comparison okay so when
you say you know human beings are just
robots made out of chemicals you're
comparing that statement to another
possibility namely that human beings are
not just robots made out of chemicals
like if you're a dualist if you are
descartes and you think that human
beings have a relationship between an
immaterial mind and a material body
then human beings are more than robots
made out of chemicals okay so the word
just is indicating the fact that in the
alternative picture there's something
extra there and and the materialist is
saying no there is nothing extra there
of course for different rhetorical
purposes in different conversational
contexts you may or may not find it
useful or helpful or wise to use that
word or not
tamim m says we come up with dark matter
to explain the mass and gravity that is
not explainable by stuff we see
what if it is just stuff that is behind
what we see just planets hiding behind
stars or more stars behind very luminous
stars
so the short answer is you know we would
have thought of that
the professional astronomers and
cosmologists would have thought of that
they you know they really try very hard
but i'm answering this question for two
reasons one is that
i do want to emphasize that nobody wants
there to be dark matter you know that
was it's never like we hope there's dark
matter out there let's find reasons to
believe in it it is more complicated
less simple less uh elegant and
compelling to imagine a world with dark
matter than a world in which the matter
that we already know about explains
everything we see so be not much nicer
your first guess as a good scientist is
always that we should work hard to
explain the stuff the observations we
make in terms of things we know about
and astronomers and cosmologists and
physicists do that but they conclude
that they can't
fit the data by doing that and that's
why they are driven to posit dark matter
the other thing is that we measure how
much dark matter there is etc by looking
at stars and galaxies and their dynamics
but those are far in a way not the only
pieces of evidence that we have in fact
the best evidence we have that dark
matter is not ordinary matter comes from
a combination of cosmological data with
the cosmic microwave background big bang
nucleosynthesis and so forth big bang
nucleosynthesis tells us the rate of
expansion of the universe and the amount
of ordinary matter in the universe when
hydrogen was being converted into helium
at early times okay so we know how much
ordinary matter there is none of it can
be hiding we have measured how much
ordinary matter there is from the
reaction products of nuclear fusion in
the early universe
then at the same time using the
microwave background and other pieces of
data we know the total amount of matter
we know how much matter there is from
the cmb we know how much ordinary matter
there is from bbn big bang
nucleosynthesis they do not agree with
each other so even if you ignored all of
the data from galaxies from clusters
from the growth of large-scale structure
all of that stuff you would still have
to believe in dark matter and you would
have to believe that dark matter is not
the ordinary baryonic matter hydrogen
helium etc that we know and love from
our experiments
c branch says debates are notoriously
won by persuasive speakers with
statements that are emotionally
satisfying to the audience like i said
by the way related to what i said in the
intro regardless of the truth of the
argument advertising likewise is an
attempt to persuade the target audience
to buy a product or support a candidate
rather than allowing them to make a
decision based on facts alone as a
self-serving attempt to manipulate the
thoughts and behavior of others
shouldn't persuasion itself be
considered unethical
no i do not think that persuasion itself
should be considered unethical after all
sea branch aren't you by the phrasing of
your question trying to persuade us that
persuasion should be considered
unethical persuasion is just trying to
get somebody to believe something to be
true right that's what a persuasion
means
that can be deployed for good or bad
reasons and when something can be
deployed equally well for good or bad
reasons you can't assign it an intrinsic
ethical valence as positive or negative
persuasion can be used for good reasons
as well as for bad reasons i think it is
essentially impossible to imagine
a world without persuasion you could
easily characterize teaching someone
math is trying to persuade them that the
mathematical theorems are true and that
these methods of proof are useful and so
forth persuasion can be misused but that
doesn't mean that it's somehow ethically
bad i mean i could go on with examples
but i think you get the point of what
i'm saying
m masela says your enthusiasm in both
tone and cadence and the use of the word
stuff in amaze always makes me smile it
makes me think of the classic george
carlin monologue on this subject were
you by any chance a fan of his uh yeah i
was absolutely a fan of george carlton
not like a super fan i don't have all
the albums or whatever but i always
enjoyed his take on things i thought he
was a both very very funny a great
comedian and you know i liked his
attitude his perspective on things which
you can't separate right i mean
comedians have
angles they have perspectives on things
and and george carlin and mine are very
much uh compatible with each other i
know the monologue you're thinking about
uh
what is the point of it um i'm happy to
use slightly naughty language here uh
the point of it was i'm not gonna get
the details right but other people's
stuff is their [ __ ] and your [ __ ] is
stuff or vice versa i forget what it is
but anyway i don't
think that my pronunciation or cadence
of the word stuff is influenced by that
but uh it might be that i just don't
know you know
it's not always the case that we know
why we do things that's why it's what i
referenced just earlier about
you know what do i change my mind about
what impact does being a physicist have
on my beliefs these are not things that
you can always pinpoint with a lot of
precision so maybe
tim gianitzos says great podcast with
judea pearl you both agree that
causation does not exist in fundamental
physics because all physical phenomena
work in the same way whether being run
forward or backward in time i don't
understand how this bears on the
question if i explain the trajectory of
a particle as being caused by a
collision it had at a previous time why
would you describe this as a convenient
shorthand rather than just as a
fundamental observation well it in part
depends on what you mean by causation
and both pearl and i in that case we're
thinking of the cause and effect
relationships that we observe in the
manifest image in the everyday view of
the world if you have
fundamental physics with very few moving
parts and everything is reversible you
might think well i can ascribe causality
to what happened earlier and then say
you know if it happened if something
like a collision had not happened that
way earlier then the present situation
would be different therefore it's going
to cause effect relationship but what
you find is that the same thing works
backwards in time right i can say well
because i will in the future
have a certain collision if i weren't
going to have that collision i must be
on a different trajectory now and
therefore my trajectory now is caused by
that future collision okay
if you can say it one way you can say it
the other way and therefore whatever
you're talking about is not the everyday
notion of causality in our everyday
notion of causality causes have to
precede effects and it's not just a
convention right it's not like well we
chose it one way or the other there's a
reason why that is true we think we have
causal influence over events in the
future but we don't think we have causal
influence over events in the past and
that kind of distinction wouldn't be
possible at the level of fundamental
physics it is crucial at the level of
the macroscopic world and therefore we
have to explain why
jimmy summer says i've recently
revisited searle's chinese room thought
experiment and it's much more
interesting to me now i know about the
universality of computation so in my
view there's nothing inherently
impossible about simulating a human
brain and therefore all the
phenomenology that comes along with it
but i'm still not sure what the correct
response to the chinese room is if i
might ask what's your best guess at
what's going on there
so for people who don't know the chinese
room thought experiment uh from
philosopher john searle says you know
imagine a gigantic warehouse full of
punch cards and other you know very
low-tech things
and there is a person who is an english
speaker in the house and all the punch
cards are relationships and computations
that relate to things that can be said
in the chinese language so there's an
input people put in little other cards
that have chinese characters on them and
this english-speaking person inside i
hope i'm getting it right the
description goes through some procedure
to relate that card to other cards you
know maybe move some cards around has
memories or whatever and then
spits out some response that is also in
chinese and what searle is saying is
look
the person who is doing that the actual
agent that is moving around and
shuffling the cards they don't
understand chinese right there's
something missing in the idea of
comprehension of the chinese language in
that kind of thought experiment and of
course what he means is that you
materialists think the human brain
really is like that right some
some stimulus comes in sensory input and
it goes through our brain in some
mechanistic algorithmic way and then we
spit out a response so he wants to argue
against that as being true understanding
he wants to say there's more to
consciousness and understanding than
that and of course there's an extremely
obvious response that was made right
away which is
sure the person inside the chinese room
doesn't understand chinese but the room
understands chinese and the only thing
that the whole thought experiment is
doing
is trying to make
consciousness in a materialistic sense
seem silly by
intuition pumping on our feelings about
computation right you know the human
brain has what 85 billion
neurons and some trillions of syntax
synaptic connections between them and
you can say oh yeah just imagine
replacing neurons by punch cards in a
big room
that room would be really really big
and the speed at which these
computations go is much much faster in
the brain than they would be with a
little dude moving cards around okay so
because it is so far outside our usual
experience to us that doesn't seem like
a conscious creature but all he's done
is do a one-to-one map between what goes
on in real people and replace neurons
with punch cards and things like that
okay so if like me
you think there's nothing more going on
in the brain than what goes on in the
neurons and our other cells and organs
and so forth then you have to believe
that that room with a little person in
it understands chinese and i have no
trouble believing that whatsoever so i
see no impact in any special way of the
thought experiment
okay rick antle asks a priority question
and he's cheating a little bit because
it is long
and remember you're supposed to ask
short questions but i think that this
once because it's a priority question i
will uh i will answer it even though
it's pretty long
so rick says i am part of a small group
of accounting scholars who are deeply
interested in theories of information
and complexity
virtually all the accounting scholarship
on information relies either explicitly
or implicitly on bayesian style analysis
while this approach has been fruitful in
yielding some qualitative results this
lack of crisp quantitative experimental
evidence and the lack of a model of
information processing call information
processing costs has greatly limited our
progress in an attempt to come at our
issues from a new direction we have been
studying quantum information
superposition entanglement density
matrices etc we are unclear about the
relationship between quantum information
models and bayesian ones there are two
sides to this issue number one does
there always exist a bayesian type model
with a classical phase space a priori
distribution and bayesian updating that
it could explain any experimental
results that could be explained within a
quantum information model and number two
if both quantum and bayesian approaches
are used to model the same phenomenon
does the quantum model imply
restrictions on the bayesian model
okay so i'm going to have to confess
that i'm not quite sure what it what
counts as the scope of what you're
calling a bayesian model i mean like
i've already mentioned bayes's theorem
is a theorem it's a theorem about
updating a probability distribution and
that theorem is a hundred percent just
as true in quantum mechanics as it is in
classical mechanics now quantum
information is a different kind of thing
than classical information and basically
the way in which it's different is
mostly because of entanglement there's
other issues you can get into but
entanglement says that the information
if you have a composite system with
subsystems a and b
then the information in the system as a
whole cannot be localized so that it's
the information in a plus the
information in b okay that's the big
insight in quantum information so for
example you can have an entropy entropy
is an information theoretic uh quantity
if there's an information theoretic
version of entropies what i should say
it was first a thermodynamic quantity
but entropy is telling you how much
uncertainty there is in your overall
probability distribution a delta
function a single point where you know
exactly what the probability is that
sorry exact with exact certainty what
the system is doing has zero entropy
whereas if you have a lot of uncertainty
it has a large amount of entropy and in
classical physics therefore if i have a
box of gas
if i don't know what any of the gas
molecules are doing that's a lot of
entropy if i know precisely what all the
gas molecules are doing it is zero
entropy whereas in quantum mechanics if
i have again a bipartite system that is
to say a system with two pieces in it a
and b
i can have the following situation where
i know exactly the quantum state of the
whole system so the system as a whole
has zero entropy
but if i divide it up into system a and
system b system a and system b
separately have a non-zero entropy
because they are entangled with each
other whereas classically that can't
happen because classically if i know in
a box of gas the position and velocity
of every molecule then i also know the
position and velocity of every molecule
in every subset of the box okay so there
is a difference between quantum and
classical information because of
entanglement and my guess would be
without pers without quite addressing
your question but my guess would be that
there is zero applicability of quantum
information theory to accounting
because this crucial property of
entanglement just doesn't exist in the
macroscopic world where accounting is
relevant so unless you're really doing
accounting with respect to small quantum
entangled systems then i don't think
it's going to be of any help whatsoever
now
is there some analogy is there some way
in which quantum information ideas can
be helpful in understanding ordinary
accounting practices etc you know maybe
but i'm a little skeptical there too to
be honest i would think that you can do
everything with ordinary classical
probability theory perfectly well it's
possible that i don't understand enough
about accounting to give you the right
answer there but that would be my guess
sid huff says you have on several
occasions defended the importance of
philosophy in the search for truth
particularly regarding cosmology and
fundamental physics in the june ama you
chastised richard feynman for his
dismissal philosophy is useless in this
regard can you give us an example or two
of ways in which you believe
philosophers have contributed to our
understanding of either fundamental
physics or cosmology yeah i mean i can
give you many many examples i mean
there's many historical examples we've
already talked about einstein inventing
general relativity right he was hugely
influenced by philosophical ideas by
especially by ernst mock and a sort of
relational view about the nature of
space and things within it boltzmann was
very influenced by philosophical ideas
obviously niels bohr when he invented
complementarity and quantum mechanics
hugely influenced by uh philosophical
ideas i myself have been influenced by
uh philosophical ideas philosophers have
done a much better job than physicists
at clarifying the issues and the
possible solutions to things like the
arrow of time problem and the quantum
measurement problem
you know you can't expect philosophers
to invent new correct theories of
physics that's not their job they're not
very good at it sometimes they try i'm
not very impressed with what they do but
i'm extremely impressed with how they
tell you why your theory of physics is
not right it's cheating or it has hidden
assumptions in it or it's intellectually
inconsistent with other things about
other things we know various ways in
which you can do better you know
physicists as i said in the recent um
solo episode about the philosophy of the
multiverse
physicists are are impatient and sloppy
sometimes
the multiverse is a an example where i
think that most physicists these days
are getting it wildly wrong
and i don't think that philosophers have
really put their
effort into getting it right as much as
they should so i'm hoping for
insight from philosophers in that case
but that's what philosophers are really
good at they're they're good at
clarifying the conceptual underpinnings
of things and there are parts of physics
that really can benefit from that
rue philip says
i believe i've heard you say that it's
reasonable to think eventually
everything will end up in black holes
and black holes will eventually
evaporate leaving nothing but useless
long wavelength radiation what i don't
understand is why do we think everything
will end up in black holes for example
say a star or planet gets ejected from a
galaxy and heads into intergalactic
space then the space around that object
is always expanding away from it
couldn't it be possible that everything
including black holes will expand away
from it forever and leaving it to wait
for proton decay um yeah that's possible
that's completely possible but it's a
tiny fraction i think i think most
things will end up in black holes
proton decay by the way is not something
that we are sure even happens we have
good theoretical reason to think it does
but we're not absolutely sure
we do have equally good theoretical
reason to think that even without proton
decay something like a planet or or a
white dwarf or a neutron star will
quantum tunnel into a black hole
so even something like that even without
proton decay things don't last forever
and you can sort of justify that just by
thinking about entropy
whatever kind of thing you have if you
have a planet let's say
you can turn that planet into a black
hole of equal mass and the entropy will
be higher
and then that black hole can radiate
into radiation and the entropy will be
higher still so if there's no conserved
quantities or whatever like electric
charge that get in the way of a process
like that happening if the process
increases the entropy of the universe
eventually it's probably going to happen
so i mean it's a little slightly casual
approximate statement when we say
everything falls into black holes but
it's not doing violence to the ultimate
conclusion you draw from this
p walder says what do you consider are
the reasons for the success of science
from the enlightenment to the present
day
is it in essence a change of mindset to
focus on popparian falsifiability kunian
paradigm shifts straven's iron rule the
preeminence of empirical data collection
or something else
well uh i don't think it's any of those
things
because those are all very very after
the fact popper kuhn and stevens are all
20th century people or 21st century in
case of michael strievens who's a
philosophy a philosopher of science
but science was pretty successful long
before that i do think that there was a
shift but you know this is something
where this is a job for a real historian
of science which is not me but in these
cases where
you have both the shift in how people
act and a shift in how they justify why
they are acting
it's usually a complicated interplay
between those two things rather than a
shift in beliefs and then following that
a shift in behavior so i think that in
the case of science it wasn't that
people sat down and said okay let's
invent the scientific method and then
started doing it they started doing it
and then they sat down and said hmm what
is this thing that is going on that
seems to be so successful
empirical measurements
hypothesis testing things like that
being open-minded about different
alternatives rather than trying to use
deduction to derive the correct things
all these are various sets of ideas that
go into the informal procedure that we
label the scientific method
and uh it all kind of happened uh but
it's a mishmash i mean that's that's
what history is very often like i think
that ultimately if you have to give one
single reason why it was successful in
terms of
people believing this was a good thing
to do
it's because it worked
right this kind of
reasoning
paid off paid dividends in in terms of a
better understanding of the universe and
so people began to think deeply about
why it was working so well we're still
thinking deeply about that we don't
completely know the answer
okay last question this has been a good
long ama hope you're all getting
something out of it so for those of you
who have stuck around less questions
from lucas brombink who says i was super
excited to hear you'll be joining johns
hopkins as a new faculty member i'm sad
to have missed you by a few years but
while i was there i studied neuroscience
and philosophy with a particular
interest in the philosophy of science
what type of courses or material do you
intend to teach
so thanks i'm glad that you're excited
i'm excited too you know i will my
job title is professor of natural
philosophy which i made up i you know
there's no
no um
department of natural philosophy it's
just me but in practice what that means
is i spend time in both the physics
department and the philosophy
departments and i'll be teaching in both
physics and philosophy and i can teach
roughly speaking whatever i want and so
i'm going to be teaching a variety of
things you know within physics
department like you still when you teach
a course there still needs to be
department for it you can't completely
escape the bureaucracy of the university
but they're pretty flexible about you
know how they uh
categorize different courses and things
like that at hopkins which is good for
me so
i'm teaching a first-year seminar on the
physics of democracy where you know we
talk about
how we can use
ideas from physics from phase
transitions and uh condensed matter
systems and complex systems to better
understand society and how it self
organizes the you know the common thread
being that both
in physics and in democracy we have
emergence right we have collective
behavior that is the that is the
important connecting tissue there and
i'm also teaching an upper level seminar
on the topics in the philosophy of
physics where we'll talk about the arrow
of time and quantum mechanics and the
multiverse going forward i certainly
hope on the physics side of things to
teach more ordinary courses like quantum
mechanics or general relativity i also
very much would like to teach a physics
course on complex systems there's some
good textbooks out there i know a little
bit about the subject but i want to
learn more there's no better way to
learn more than to teach courses about
it on the philosophy side you know i'm
easing into it by teaching stuff that i
know very well in the philosophy of
physics
but going forward i would hope to you
know both teach more advanced graduate
level seminars in some of these topics
when we are able to uh attract even more
graduate students in the philosophy of
physics and postdocs you know i don't
know if it's been uh i know that i've
mentioned on twitter i don't know if i
mentioned on the postdoc here but janan
ismail who is a former mindscape guest
and a leading philosopher of physics is
also coming to johns hopkins and maybe
some other people as well so we'll have
a very good group in philosophy of
physics and and related ideas
so i think that's gonna lead to more
people who are interested in those
subjects coming to hopkins um so yeah
we'll have more advanced subjects on
that and then you know ideas like
emergence and uh reduction and
complexity can also be taught from a
philosophical point of view and then
what i would really like is to become
good enough to teach more standard
philosophy courses maybe even you know
moral or political philosophy who knows
logic uh
um ethics you know we don't know i don't
i don't know who's who's to say i'm a
professor in the department i can think
about what is available there and that's
what is really really exciting and fun
to me there's so many things that
i would like to learn and would like to
know more about and would like to talk
to people about and you know that's what
philosophers are good at so i'm looking
forward to it so i am also very very
excited i'm glad you are lucas i'm glad
everyone here has listened to this whole
long thing thanks for your support
especially the patreon supporters i
really do appreciate it thanks for
everyone who listens to mindscape and
i'll see you next week month slash year
bye bye
[Music]
you